juste comme vous l'avez d'ailleurs
rappelé en effet entreprise mais là je
vais pouvoir public doit participer au
défi de l'adaptation climatique mais
chacun selon ses moyens il faudra être
extrêmement ambitieux sur tous les
fronts celui de la conversion des outils
de production agricoles industrielle ou
encore celui de la lutte contre le
gaspillière et de l'eau y compris des
eaux grises et usées dans les normes
d'usage devront être rapidement révisés
pour compenser le déficit croissant à
nos clairs tout cela va nécessiter un
accompagnement conséquent je pense en
particulier aux collectivités locales
qui devront être soutenus pour faire
face à leurs besoins nombreux en matière
de révolution énergétique des
caractéristiques des questions des
déchets ou de mobilité celle-ci
bénéficie déjà du fond vert puissiez
question de planifier l'écologie le fond
vert sera-t-il pérennisé à long terme
avec quel montant au-delà des 2
milliards d'euros déjà prévus et quel
pouvez-vous en faire
pour vous répondre à la parole est à
madame la Première ministre vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le
peu de Ruquier je veux tout d'abord à
mon tour exprimer toute ma solidarité au
collègue et aux proches des agents
décédés tragiquement ces derniers jours
et exprimer tout tout mon soutien tout
le soutien de mon gouvernement aux
agents qui s'engagent chaque jour pour
nous protéger nous soigner assurer
l'éducation de nos enfants et parfois
malheureusement au péril de leur vie
alors monsieur le Président Roquier en
effet un chaque jour les conséquences du
dérèglement climatique deviennent plus
visibles et préoccupantes je pense
notamment aux sécheresse de ces derniers
mois ou encore au feu de forêt nous
avons besoin d'une action forte pour
limiter le dérèglement climatique pour
nous adapter à ces conséquences
inéluctables et pour restaurer notre
biodiversité nous prenons des mesures
sans attendre c'est le sens du plan o
qui a été présenté par le Président de
la République ou encore du renforcement
des moyens pour la sécurité civile et je
voudrais souligner le Senn qui contribue
pleinement avec la proposition de loi
pour mieux prévenir les feux de forêt
sur laquelle une commission mixte
paritaire se réunira prochainement et
pour réussir la transition écologique
nous devons planifier des actions de
long terme pour notre biodiversité pour
la gestion de nos ressources naturelles
et pour limiter nos émissions de gaz à
effet de serre vous le savez nous nous
sommes fixés des objectifs ambitieux au
niveau européen nous sommes en avance
sur nos objectifs
2019-2023 et nous avons pratiquement
rattrapé le retard accumulé sur la
période 2015-2018 mais il nous faut
encore accélérer et doubler le rythme de
réduction des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre depuis le mois de septembre
avec les ministres et l'ensemble des
acteurs nous avons identifié secteur par
secteur les leviers à actionner pour
baisser nos émissions et pour être
acceptable vous l'avez souligné l'effort
doit être juste et équitablement rép la
moitié reviendra aux entreprises
notamment les grandes entreprises un
quart sera réalisé par l'État et les
collectivités et un quart par les
ménages et pour être réussi la
transition écologique doit aussi se
faire avec nos concitoyens nous devons
les accompagner dans les changements à
venir et former au métier de la
transition écologique j'ai réuni lundi
un conseil national de la transition
écologique pour partager nos objectifs
secteurs par secteur et dans le courant
du mois de juin nous serons en mesure de
présenter une planification écologique
complète mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs réussir la transition
écologique c'est aussi nous adapter et
anticiper tous les cas de figure le
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires a annoncé
le week-end dernier le lancement de
travaux pour préparer la France en cas
de hausse des températures de 4 degrés
que ce soit pour réduire nos émissions
de gaz à effet de serre pour nous
adapter aux effets inéluctables du
dérèglement climatique ou pour restaurer
la biodiversité nous avons besoin des
collectivités de nombreux projets
concrets se mettent en place notamment
grâce au soutien du fond vert se font ce
sont deux milliards d'euros des cette
année et je vous confirme comme je
l'avais annoncé que se font sera
pérennisé je vous remercie merci
monsieur le Président routier le combat
pour le climat sera long et difficile
mais comme une équipe de rugby ne
gagnerons ou nous le perdrons tous
ensemble merci
la parole est à notre collègue Jacques
verdict pour le groupe écologie
solidarité et territoire merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre des
Transports Clément Beaune justement si
on veut gagner tous ensemble est-ce
vraiment le moment de saper le frais de
ferroviaire public comment Monsieur le
Ministre
sont fixer les trajectoires du Plan
Climat comment peut-on viser le report
de la route vers le rail et accepter en
même temps que Fret SNCF l'acteur public
majeur de cette transition indispensable
soit dépecée démantelé la Commission
européenne par sa procédure contre la
France pour être d'État soit disant
illégal à Fret SNCF mais en péril la
survie même de cet acteur essentiel à la
mutation des transports monsieur le
ministre ce n'est pas par des procédures
technocratiques par l'application
aveugle d'une doxa libérale que l'Europe
réussira mais par sa capacité qu'à sa
capacité à concrétiser son Green Deal à
atteindre un objectif européen 2030 du
frais de ferroviaire à 30% de par modal
la France en est encore loin ça commence
à bouger ne laissons pas briser cet élan
entre la cause du climat et celle de la
concurrence le choix est une évidence
monsieur le ministre plutôt que de tenir
cette ligne résolue vous préférez en
prendre votre partie et consentir à en
finir avec SNCF tel qu'il existe
aujourd'hui le liquidé pour lui
substituer avec deux entités une
structure assez différente pour que la
DG Concurrence admettent la
discontinuité économique comme il disent
et donc renonce à exiger le
remboursement des aides abandons des
trains complets de 500 emplois garantie
sociale et salariale en danger sérieux
ouverture du capital session d'une part
des locomotives aux concurrents
renoncement aux appels d'offres pour des
années pour le trafic dédié monsieur le
ministre comment ce scénario de mise à
la découpe pourrait-il ne pas briser le
rebond ferroviaire nécessaire serez-vous
le ministre des Transports qui a liquidé
frais SNCF
pour vos réponses la parole est au
ministre déléguée en charge des
transports monsieur Beaune
merci merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur fernd comme vous je
crois très fermement à l'avenir du frais
de ferroviaire et c'est une part
essentielle de notre stratégie de
planification écologique et d'ailleurs
avec le plan Fred qui est déployé depuis
maintenant deux ans nous avons inversé
une tendance historique qui était celle
du recul de la part du frais de
ferroviaire dans le transport de
marchandises en France pour la première
fois depuis 2015 cette part est en train
de réaugmenter et nous ne lâcherons pas
cette ambition que nous partageons je
crois tous ici pour cela il faut en
effet un opérateur public de référence
du frais de ferroviaire et je suis bien
déterminé à le maintenir quelle est la
situation monsieur le sénateur par une
faut dire la vérité sans faciliter et
sans démagogie pour préparer l'avenir
c'est qu'il y a en effet une procédure
qui a été ouverte publiquement le 18
janvier dernier par la Commission
européenne après plusieurs échanges avec
la France je me suis occupé le ces
dossiers dès mon arrivée au ministère
des Transports il y a un peu moins d'un
an j'ai tout fait nous avons tout fait
du côté des autorités françaises pour
empêcher l'ouverture la procédure pour
contester comme vous venez de le faire
les aides réputées illégales sont la
Commission européenne versées pendant 15
ans par les gouvernements successifs à
Fret SNCF la procédure a été engagée et
donc nous avons aujourd'hui un choix qui
est simple et clair et que nous devons
partager soit nous disons que nous
allons en effet jusqu'au bout de cette
procédure c'est une possibilité mais
disons-le aussi très franchement le
risque est simple et c'est une quasi
certitude c'est la mort totale et cette
fois la liquidation de fret SNCF 4800
salariés et des milliers de kilomètres
aujourd'hui de rail et de Fred
ferroviaire en France je ne veux pas de
cette solution et donc oui j'assume que
en responsabilité pour ne pas mettre en
danger les femmes et les hommes du frais
de ferroviaire pour garder un groupe
public de frais de ferroviaire qui a un
avenir et que nous soutiendrons nous
devons trouver le plus rapidement
possible un accord pour mettre fin à
l'incertitude et éviter la mort de cette
opérateur nous aurons un opérateur
public nous aurons un opérateur qui ne
sera pas privatisé qui gardera l'immense
majorité de ses activités sans aucun lic
enciement évidemment et sans aucun
report modal car j'y suis engagé nous
réinvestissons en même temps dans le
frais de ferroviaire de manière
totalement inédite nous amplifions
encore le plan déployé depuis 2021 pour
renforcer cette ambition
monsieur Véronique oui monsieur le
ministre vous disais ne pas vouloir
mettre en danger vous avez parlé de
jouer à la roulette russe l'avenir du
fret ferroviaire mais dans quel jeu
risqué l'engageez-vous en croyant
qu'avec une telle désorganisation les
chargeurs les acteurs économiques ne
retourneront pas à la route ne resteront
pas dans les camions
la parole est notre collègue Danny Blade
pour le groupe Les Indépendants
républicains
monsieur le Président Monsieur Miss
intérieur mes chers collègues
notre pays traverse une semaine noire
hier matin nous apprenions au décès
d'une infirmière sauvagement agressée
dimanche matin Paul m'annon Steven ont
succombé un accident du Lancy nuit dans
les assises de leur fonction dans le
Nord
ces trois policiers de moins de 25 ans
étaient au début de leur carrière et
avait toute la vie devant eux
l'un d'entre eux était pas de famille
d'un enfant de 11 mois tandis qu'un
autre allait devenir père monsieur le
ministre vous êtes venu rencontrer leurs
collègues lundi je vous en remercie le
groupe Les Indépendants veulent rendre
un vif hommage et mes premières pensées
vont à l'ensemble du Fally meurtri et
elle a de l'adolescente qui venait de
secourir
après la douleur
et la colère viendra le temps des
questions
on sait désormais que les deux occupants
du véhicule ayant percuté ses
fonctionnaires
sont connus pour usage stupéfiant et
d'alcool on apprend ensuite que le
chauffard conduisait sous l'emprise de
ces substances
les policiers gendarmes et pompiers ces
héros du quotidien sont de plus en plus
confrontés à des violences
insupportables et intolérables lors de
leurs interventions
comme de nombreux événements récents
nous le rappelle à chaque drame
l'émotion est plus forte
ce climat docilité est nourri par le
silence assourdissant de certains
soucieux d'entretenir une atmosphère de
défiance envers les forces de l'ordre
ces femmes et ces hommes sont le garant
sont les garants de l'ordre républicain
il mérite une protection et un soutien
encore plus fort et surtout intangibles
mais il faut que la justice suive
monsieur le ministre je vous avais deux
questions quelles mesures attendez-vous
prendre afin de soutenir et de compagner
les familles des victimes dans cette
période
vous pouvez nous dire comment le
gouvernement entend poursuivre son
action pour soutenir nos forces de
sécurité intérieure contre les multiples
menaces auxquelles elles sont
confrontées
[Applaudissements]
la parole Sonia baquet
secrétaire d'été en charge de la
citoyenneté
le président et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur
effectivement vous l'avez dit le métier
les métiers de policier et gendarmes
sont des métiers de plus en plus
difficiles eu égard aux exigences
légitimes de nos concitoyens et au
risque et aux menaces qui pèsent sur eux
ils ont besoin de tout notre soutien
pardon et à ce titre je me joins aux
hommages qui ont été rendus à
l'Assemblée nationale et ici même et par
la première ministre aux trois policiers
qui sont décédés la semaine dernière
dans l'exercice de leur fonction depuis
le 1er janvier dernier ce sont 2380
gendarmes et policiers qui ont été
blessés dans l'exercice de leur fonction
et on peut souligner
ce policier blessé lors de la
manifestation du 1er mai par un cocktail
Molotov et tous ceux qui ont été blessés
dans le cadre des manifestations qui ont
eu lieu ces dernières semaines
le Parlement a voté la loopmie et il
m'appartient de vous remercier qui a
doté la police et la gendarmerie de
moyens exceptionnels des moyens humains
et budgétaires d'abord avec 15 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires et des moyens
statutaires qui permettent de valoriser
de mieux prendre en compte la carrière
de nos de nos militaires de nos
gendarmes et de nos policiers nous
entendons bien évidemment et c'est
l'objet de votre question pour suivre
nos efforts pour mieux protéger les
policiers les gendarmes c'est déjà en
cours de déploiement puisque ce sont des
caméras de piétons qui sont développées
qui sont déployés pardon dans tous les
commissariats c'est une protection
fonctionnelle qui est facilité c'est une
cellule d'assistance aux policiers
victimes qui a été créé en 2021 et c'est
de nouveau de nouveaux équipements qui
lui permettent leur protection physique
avec des casques lourds des casques
pardon et des gilets lourds
nous avons également grâce au soutien du
Parlement créé le délit spécifique
de violences volontaires sur argent sur
agent pardon chargé de la sécurité
intérieure et de protection des agents
en bord de route la locmi a également
créé 20 postes de psychologues qui
permet pardon d'accompagner au mieux les
policiers et les gendarmes le ministre
de l'intérieur est très attentif à la
protection des forces de sécurité
intérieure avec l'aide du Parlement je
vous remercie
la parole est à notre collègue Christine
lavard pour le groupe les républicains
monsieur le ministre 2023 mois de mars
avec la plus faible natalité depuis 1994
2022 année avec la plus faible fécondité
depuis 1945 pourquoi les Français
ont-ils moins d'enfants on pourrait
penser à l'échoanxiété on pourrait
surtout penser aux problèmes du logement
cela fait des mois que les élus locaux
vous alerte sur la crise du logement et
pourtant le Conseil national de la
refondation consacrée à ce sujet a été
reporté cinédié il devait se tenir le 9
mai on pourrait penser au manque de
moyens financiers sous François Hollande
le quotient familial les allocations
familiales ont diminué sous Emmanuel
Macron les allocations familiales ont
été faiblement revalorisées la CMG a
diminué alors que les 1000 premiers
jours alors que il existe des excédents
la branche famille 1,9 milliards
d'excédents en 2022 après 2,9 milliards
en 2021 5,8 milliards d'erreurs
comptables le constat est sévère la
sentence sans appel la cour des comptes
a refus de valider les comptes de la
branche famille pour 2022 mais aussi
difficulté à faire garder les enfants de
moins de trois ans alors que les 1000
premiers jours avaient été érigés comme
une priorité aucune des préconisations
du rapport cyrunique n'a trouvé une
traduction législative ou réglementaire
la conférence des familles de 2022
annonce un droit opposable à la garde
pour 2027 un rapport de ligase du 11
avril dernier dénonce la baisse de la
qualité d'accueil la restitution du CNR
petite enfance prévue au mois de mars
reporté elle aussi cinédiée la cause la
future coche est toujours en cours de
discussion elle sera donc connue des
acteurs avec au moins plus de trois mois
de retard le constat est sombre alors
Monsieur le Ministre qu'allez-vous
proposer au président de la République
qui semble enfin s'inquiéter des
chiffres alarmants de la natalité
pour vous répondre la parole est homélie
des solidarités
de l'autonomie une personne handicapée
monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice la barbe vous abordez
plusieurs questions dans votre question
je voudrais revenir d'abord sur la
question de l'annonce certification des
comptes par la Cour des comptes des
comptes 2022 de la branche famille de la
sécurité sociale qui nous interroge à la
fois sur les difficultés qui ont pu
conduire à cette non certification qui
remet pas en question d'ailleurs la
bonne tenue des comptes de la branche
mais qui dénonce à certains nombre de
problématiques en matière de contrôle
interne de la branche auquel nous
verrons à remédier à la fois en
travaillant sur la sécurisation du
système avec le projet de solidarité à
la source pour veiller à une meilleure
versement des prestations sociales à une
simplification en luttant contre le non
recours en limitant contre la fraude et
en luttant contre les indus dans la
branche et vous abordez une deuxième
question qui est celle de la question de
la natalité dans notre pays alors vous
le savez le taux de natalité aujourd'hui
proche de 1,8 enfants par femme c'est un
taux de natalité qui est en forte baisse
et qui ne permet pas le renouvellement
des générations dans notre pays qui doit
tous nous inquiéter parce que il pose un
certain nombre de problèmes notamment il
fait peser sur notre système de
protection sociale des tensions qui sont
extrêmement fortes et donc mon rôle en
tant que ministre des familles et de la
petite enfance c'est aussi bien de
répondre aujourd'hui à l'envie des
familles de pouvoir avoir des enfants
dans notre pays puisque on sait que le
désir d'enfant et d'environ 2,4 enfants
par femme ce que nous nous pensons c'est
que avant de penser augmenter les
prestations ou les allocations
familiales pour pouvoir favoriser ce
voilà cette réponse à ce désir d'enfant
c'est d'abord d'améliorer les services
aux familles et comme vous l'avez dit
l'une des premières préoccupations
aujourd'hui des familles dans notre pays
c'est de savoir comment elles vont
pouvoir faire garder leur enfant on le
sait il manquerait environ 200 000
places d'accueil
du jeune enfant le président de la
République s'est engagé à mettre en
place ce service public de la petite
enfance la première ministre aura des
annonces dans les jours qui viennent
pour vous dire comment nous répondrons à
cette question
merci
[Musique]
pour autant
des accompagnations SRU supprimer la
modulation des allocations familiales
supprimer la tarification horaires de la
psq qui est complexe et qui engendre
nombre de Ford donner un véritable
pouvoir de sanction au PMI monsieur le
ministre à chaque enfant qui n'est le
monde recommence une politique familiale
ambitieuse et la meilleure réforme des
retraites vous disposez de 6 milliards
pour financer cette politique merci
[Musique]
la parole est à notre collègue Stéphane
de Minnie pour le gros psy de l'Union
centriste monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur je souhaite vous parler d'un
sujet de fond très grave mais
permettez-moi de le faire par le biais
d'une rhétorique un peu inhabituelle
celle d'une charade une charade
intitulée je fais ce que je veux quand
je veux comme je veux et où je veux mon
premier est une manifestation dite
musicale interdite par deux arrêtés
préfectoraux mon deuxième a réuni malgré
l'état de droit dans lequel nous vivons
plus de 30 000 personnes dans un petit
village de l'Indre qui a subitement vu
sa population multipliée par 273 pour
devenir l'espace d'un long weekend la
capitale de la race party
mon troisième malgré la mobilisation de
320 gendarmes c'est soldé par plus de
500 prises en charge par les services de
secours dont 30 évacués en urgence
absolue mon quatrième à générer 15
tonnes de déchets dans le terrain privé
d'un propriétaire qui a vu converger en
quelques heures sans en être averti une
marée humaine de teuffeur et mon tout
monsieur le ministre apporte de l'eau
moules de ceux qui s'inquiètent du
délitement de l'autorité de l'État
Michel ministre cet épisode du teknival
est loin d'être isolé d'autres
départements y compris le mien ayant dû
subir cette dictature de l'urgence et de
la masse je sais bien comme le rappeler
Machiavel que le choix est rarement
entre le bien et le mal mais entre le
pire et le moindre mal mais j'ai
néanmoins deux questions à vous poser à
propos de cet épisode affligent
la première est peut-être naïve mais
comment se fait-il que tout le monde
était au courant de ce rassemblement
sauf ceux qui devaient l'être ma
deuxième question est d'ordre
pragmatique pour dissuader ce genre
d'événements illégaux et dangereux sans
parler de l'alcool et de la drogue ne
faut-il pas durcir les sanctions contre
les organisateurs qui aujourd'hui
individuellement ne risque rien si ce
n'est 1500 euros d'amende monsieur le
ministre ces images de temps de
désinvolture ont une résonance terrible
dans l'opinion publique mais je pense
que vous le savez
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
secrétaire d'État en charge de la
citoyenneté madame baquet
le sénateur demi vous nous interrogez
sur le rassemblement festif musical du
17 mai dernier baptisé technival French
tech 2023 et comme vous l'avez dit il a
été non déclaré aucune demande
d'autorisation n'a été faite les
renseignements territoriaux puisque
c'est votre première question avait bien
identifié l'organisation en cours d'une
manifestation de ce type dans le centre
de la France mais et vous le savez aussi
le lieu exact a été défini quelques
heures avant le rassemblement et ce sont
en quelques heures jusqu'à 25000
personnes qui se sont réunies sur le
site et dans l'urgence ont été organisés
cet événement pardon alors que et vous
l'avez dit les conditions ne s'y
prêtaient absolument pas ni d'un point
de vue sanitaire ni d'un point de vue de
la sécurité
sous l'autorité du préfet et en urgence
et je veux remercier les services de
l'État qui se sont rendus disponibles et
rendus extrêmement efficace pour
accompagner cette manifestation les
moyens de la préfecture des services de
l'État ont été mis en place les services
du département avec notamment la
mobilisation des sapeurs-pompiers et des
associations de sécurité civile le
préfet a coordonné un dispositif
opérationnel pour garantir l'ordre
public avec succès et pour garantir
d'éviter la circulation de festivaliers
qui sortait sous l'emprise de l'alcool
nous avons renforcé les moyens de
manière significative vous avez parlé de
320 gendarmes se sont 434 gendarmes qui
ont été mobilisés sur l'opération pour
empêcher tout trouble majeur à l'ordre
public et nous pouvons je crois tous
ensemble souligner le bilan de
l'opération avec
30200 personnes et 13300 voitures qui
ont été contrôlées 155 verbalisations
pour conduite en état débriété 32
verbalisations pour stupéfiants la
saisie de 300 g de cannabis d'un kilo
d'herbes de cannabis de 40 g de cocaïne
etc etc nous avons également saisi les
groupes électrogènes et les
organisateurs pour la plupart ont été
identifiés les procédures sont en cours
et ils seront bien évidemment
sanctionnés je vous remercie
la parole de notre collègue Michel Gréau
pour le groupe communiste républicain
citoyen et écologistes
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre de
l'économie voilà plus de 60 jours que
des salariés de Vertbaudet dans le Nord
sont en grève pour rappel cette usine
est composée majoritairement de femmes
l'entreprise Vertbaudet est l'une des 59
entités détenues par le fond
d'investissement et Kinston un fond de
dimension européenne l'examen du bilan
financier de l'entreprise était
différent entre 2018 et 2021 la marge
net est passée de - 0,7% à plus de
3,6%. la valeur ajoutée de 49,7 millions
à 56,6 millions d'euros et sur la même
période la part des salaires par rapport
aux chiffres d'affaires et passer de
15,6% à
12,1%. l'unique revendication de ces
salariés est une augmentation de salaire
de 150 euros tous les chiffres montrent
que cette revendication est légitime
actuellement l'inflation les rattrapes
et les fins de mois sont difficiles
depuis deux mois pas de dialogue avec la
direction des propos sexistes à leur
égard intervention des forces de police
intimidation à la menace de licenciement
tout y passe les salariés sont
déterminés et leur lutte devient
emblématique les salaires dans
l'entreprise varient entre 1300 et 1500
euros mensuels malgré leur ancienneté
quand le dirigeant perçoit une
rémunération de 60000 euros par mois
cette grève née en lumière une question
centrale comment faire ses choix de vie
sans un salaire digne comment un
véritablement libre sans indépendance
économique la solidarité le soutien de
tout le monde du travail s'exprime y
compris financièrement et quelques par
cette lutte est devenue celle de tous
les salariés du pays par procuration
monsieur le mille et le ministre vous
prétendez appeler au partage de la
valeur n'y a-t-il pas avec Vertbaudet
une belle occasion de sa mise en oeuvre
merci pour vos réponses la parole et
communistes du travail pleine emploi et
de l'insertion monsieur dufe
merci monsieur le Président merci
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
mesdames la sénatrice vous évoquez le
conflit social en cours au sein de
l'entreprise Vertbaudet plus
particulièrement dans l'établissement
situé dans votre département
ce conflit social est bien connu des
services de mon ministère et de mon
cabinet il a été ouvert autour du 20
mars et un accord a été signé un accord
majoritaire sur lequel vous pouvez avoir
une appréciation signée par deux
organisations syndicales Force ouvrière
et la CFE-CGC en soulignant que ces deux
organisations représentent lors des
dernières consultations 63% des
suffrages exprimés dans l'entreprise la
CGT n'a pas souhaité signer cet accord
et à laisser le mouvement pour suivre et
encourager sa poursuite del 9 avril les
services de la Direction départemental
de l'économie de l'emploi du travail de
la solidarité ont initié une médiation
cette médiation s'est traduite par une
première décision de l'entreprise en
l'occurrence 30 embauches 30
recrutements de personnels en intérim
dont
sa mission d'intérim a été transformée
en contrat de travail à durée
indéterminé le 1er mai dernier l'accord
qui a été conclu fin mars prévoit une
augmentation de la rémunération mais il
est vrai pas par une voie salariale par
la mise en oeuvre de prime et d'autres
modalités de rémunération depuis depuis
il y a un certain nombre de contacts qui
ont été initiés et mon cabinet a
notamment permis un échange et un
rapprochement entre le cabinet de la
secrétaire général de la CGT madame
Guinée et la direction générale de
l'entreprise une réunion c'est à nouveau
tenue lundi dernier il y a trois jours
avec des propositions nouvelles de la
direction que la CGT a un nouveau refusé
alors nous parlons il y a environ 70
salariés sur les 340 que compte le site
qui sont toujours en grève d'autres sont
d'autres réunions sont prévues je
souhaite évidemment que le dialogue
social permette cet aboutissement dans
le respect des prérogatives de sac
chacun dans le respect aussi de l'accord
majoritaire qui a été signé il y a
maintenant quelques semaines je termine
d'un mot monsieur le Président pour dire
que madame la sénatrice a évoqué
l'intervention de la police pour
enlever et faire ôter les points de
grève les piquets de rêves cette
intervention de la police à la demande
du préfet de région a été faite en
application et une ordonnance rendue par
le tribunal saisi par l'entreprise il y
a plusieurs semaines
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Michel Dagbert pour le groupe
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants
ma question s'adresse au ministre chargé
des transports Clément bonne et porte
sur le fret ferroviaire comme quoi dans
cette hémicycle on peut poser deux fois
la même question mais sous un prisme
différent subissant la forte concurrence
de
de la part du rail dans le transport de
marchandises n'a cessé de diminuer
durant ces dernières décennies elle est
ainsi divisée par deux entre 2006 et
2019 pour passer de 20 à 10%. c'est un
fait c'est une réalité les avantages du
frais de ferroviaire sont pourtant
indéniables faisant de celui-ci un
formidable outil de la décarbonation des
activités économiques un train de
marchandises équivaut à 40 camions ils
réalisent près de 10 fois moins
d'émissions de CO2 et consomment 6 fois
moins d'énergie à la tonne transportée
que le mode routier ça aussi c'est un
fait le Conseil d'orientation des
infrastructures dans ces différents
rapports a d'ailleurs souligné
l'importance qu'il y avait à le
développer aussi le gouvernement a
affiché à plusieurs reprises sa volonté
et vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le
ministre de soutenir le transport de
marchandises par le rail l'objectif d'un
doublement de la part modale du Fred
d'ici 2030 a été inscrit dans la loi
climat et résilience du 22 août 2021 de
plus une stratégie national pour le
développement du frais de ferroviaire
comportant 72 mesures a été présentée et
170 millions d'aides supplémentaires par
an ont été alloués ce soutien
additionnel sera prolongé jusqu'en 2027
dans ce contexte les difficultés
rencontrées par la filiale de Fred de la
SNCF en effet inquiète puisque la
Commission européenne et ça a été
rappelée a démarré une procédure en
janvier aussi je sais l'investissement
qui est le votre monsieur le ministre
pouvez-vous annoncer
les mesures que vous avez annoncé hier
et nous dire le calendrier de la mise en
œuvre de ce dispositif visant à faire
perdurer le fret SNCF et à rassurer ses
salariés
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre délégués chargés les transports
monsieur bonne
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Dagbert je le redis nous vivons
une situation difficile au regard de
cette procédure engagée par la
Commission européenne et je leur ai
affirme parce que le sujet est d'une
grande gravité je ne ferai pas le choix
de la facilité qui consisterait
simplement à passer le dossier au
suivant et à verser dans quelques mois
ou quelques années des larmes de
crocodile sur l'entreprise qu'on aurait
laissé mourir par démagogie et donc je
veux régler cette situation aujourd'hui
d'ici la fin de l'année pour répondre
très précisément à votre question par un
accord oui un accord exigeant avec des
lignes rouges très précises évidemment
la préservation intégrale de l'emploi
aucun licenciement et la préservation
dans un opérateur public ferroviaire
dans l'avenir est viable de plus de 90%
des effectifs actuels je crois que c'est
une mesure très importante sans aucune
privatisation il est évident qu'il doit
y avoir un capital public au sein d'un
groupe ferroviaire qui est celui de la
SNCF et sans aucun report modal car vous
avez rappelé les avantages du frais de
ferroviaire nous assomme convaincus et
est en train de fret c'est l'équivalent
de 40 camions c'est 10 fois moins
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre nous
sommes le gouvernement qui a enfin
redressé la part du Fred ferroviaire en
France nous continuerons cela est-ce que
je propose ce n'est pas une solution du
moindre mal ça n'est pas un avenir au
rabais c'est un avenir sérieux et
positif pour le frais de ferroviaire
public et privé en France car nous
aurons besoin de beaucoup d'opérateurs
pour développer ce mode de transport et
c'est pour cela que nous avons annoncé
sous l'autorité de la première ministre
un plan amplifié et accéléré pour le
fret 200 millions d'euros seront alloués
dès la fin de l'année prochaine pour
l'aide au wagon isolé pour les aides à
l'exploitation pour les opérateurs de
fret notamment l'opérateur de Fred
ferroviaire public c'est une visibilité
donnée jusqu'à 2030 pour garantir les
investissements et le redressement de la
part du Fred ferroviaire en France dans
les contrats de plan état région ce
seront deux milliards d'euros qui seront
mobilisés en investissement 4 fois
supérieur à celui que nous avons vécu
sur la période précédente de contrat de
plan est à région pour investir dans le
garde de triage pour investir nos lignes
de fret c'est un effort qui n'a jamais
été fait dans notre pays et que nous
prolongerons de 2 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires jusqu'au début de la
décennie prochaine c'est donc un effort
dans la durée un effort sérieux je ne
veux pas qu'on vive dans l'incertitude
je veux qu'on prépare l'avenir avec les
salariés du frais de ferroviaire public
français
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Martin filleul pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
merci monsieur le Président je
souhaitais à mon tour rendre hommage aux
trois policiers de Roubaix décédé dans
l'exercice de leur fonction j'ai une
pensée pour leur famille à laquelle je
sais s'associer l'ensemble de cette
émission monsieur le ministre depuis
deux mois les 72 salariés de Verbaudet
demande à pouvoir vivre dignement du
fruit de leur travail pour beaucoup des
femmes en grève pour la première fois de
leur vie face aux rechutes de la
direction d'augmenter les salaires un
compromis dans la douleur a été trouvé
0% d'augmentation salariale mais des
primes des socialisés le délégué CFDT le
dit très clairement c'était cela ou rien
le 0% on l'a très mal vécu alors
grévistes ou non personne ne peut
trouver normal qu'après 20 ans de boîte
les salaires plafonnent au SMIC au
moment où tout augmente je partage
l'inquiétude de ces femmes salariées
grande perdante de la réforme des
retraites de ne pas voir abonder leurs
pensions avec ses primes face à un
blocage de cette nature la réponse ne
peut être celle de l'intimidation et de
la violence mais Verbaudet n'est qu'un
exemple parmi d'autres durant la période
du covid vous nous expliquer la main sur
le cœur qu'il n'y aurait un avant et un
après pour les travailleurs de première
ligne alors allez vous continuer à
dresser des vœux pieux au patronat à
coups de demandes ou bien allez-vous
enfin endosser le rôle d'un État qui
m'est réellement en pratique le partage
juste de la valeur on se plaçant au côté
des travailleurs
pour vous répondre la parole de
communiste du travail du club emploi de
l'insertion monsieur Duchamp
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice filleul je complète les propos
que j'ai tenus il y a quelques instants
réponse madame la symétrieum mais
peut-être pour évoquer deux points
premier point vous avez parlé
d'intimidation et violence et je suppose
que vous faites référence
à l'agression qui a subi un des délégués
CGT de l'entreprise en question le
délégué en question était reçu par les
représentants de la préfecture et il lui
a été vivement conseillé vous l'imaginez
de déposer plainte à l'heure où je
m'exprime devant vous et à ma
connaissance cela n'a pas été fait et il
est responsable de la Préfecture se sont
même heurté un refus de dépôt de plantes
vous évoquez madame la sénatrice
l'accord intervenu à la fin du mois de
mars je vous confirme et vous en
connaissez la teneur que cet accord
prévoit une prime à hauteur de 650 euros
de mémoire ainsi qu'un certain nombre de
dispositions relatives à la rémunération
sans qu'il y ait d'évolution salariale
particulière vous dites l'État doit
jouer son rôle nous le faisons dans le
respect du prérogatif des prérogatives
des acteurs du dialogue social à la fois
par immédiation locale par une
intervention toujours sous forme de
médiation et de prise de contact
intervention qui s'est traduite par la
réunion que j'ai évoquée il y a
l'instant qui s'est tenu avant-hier qui
n'a pas débouché sur un accord je l'ai
dit à madame la sénatrice etonne à
l'heure nous parlons 72 des presque 350
salariés de Vertbaudet sont en grève et
maintiennent leur mouvement de grève une
réunion doit se tenir en toute fin de
semaine je pense qu'un centre de
propositions seront faites et j'espère
seront de nature à avancer dans la
résolution de ce conflit mais nous
sommes face à une situation particulière
et je sais que vous entendrez je crois
en tout cas cet argument vous nous
demandez d'intervenir finalement pour
décider à la place de celles et ceux qui
sont chargés du dialogue social
l'employeur et les organisations
syndicales il y a une décision vous
pouvez porter une appréciation négative
sur l'accord intervenu à la fin du mois
de mars mais cet accord vous le savez
est considéré et à juste titre comme
majoritaire puisque signé par des
organisations syndicales représentant
63% des salariés concernés
sur le ministre de votre réponse qui ne
me satisfait que partiellement car
au-delà de l'exemple de Vertbaudet et
des volontés de négociations et bien il
y a une situation nationale qui se pose
celle de la politique salariale les
Français veulent pouvoir vivre dignement
de leur travail et aujourd'hui je
regrette que votre gouvernement ne soit
pas au rendez-vous de cette attente des
Français je vous remercie
la parole est à notre collègue Henri
Leroy pour le groupe les républicains
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre en 2022 près de 500
000 migrants légaux sont entrés en
France établissant un record absolu à
cela il faut il faut ajouter les
immigrés illégaux plus de 300000 selon
les estimations de Frontex les chèques
du gouvernement a contrôlé l'immigration
et pas tant le coût économique de cette
immigration est un sujet que le nom peut
plus éluder l'aide médicale d'État
continue de progresser de plus de 12%
cette année pour atteindre un point
culminant à 1,2 milliards d'euros et
l'accueil des immigrés pèsent de plus en
plus sur nos finances publiques le coût
social de l'immigration est de moins en
moins acceptable la loi n'est pas
respectée les auqtf ne sont pas exécutés
sans oublier le communautarisme et la
violence qui congraine notre société
touchant bien souvent les Français les
plus modestes
des solutions existent pour reprendre le
contrôle de l'immigration certains pays
comme le Danemark nous démontre qu'il
n'y a pas de fatalité mais encore
faut-il en avoir la volonté l'excellent
rapport du signateur buffet nous manque
d'ailleurs la voie en le domaine des
propositions concrètes ont été faites
par les républicains et deux
propositions de loi dont une
constitutionnelle offre de nouvelles
perspectives madame la Première ministre
la France va mal et vous regardez
ailleurs vous préférez temporiser en
adoptant une approche durant même temps
cher au président de la République
madame la Première ministre ma question
est simple quand allez-vous ouvrir les
yeux sur le drame qui se joue sous vos
yeux et vous emparé sérieusement de ce
sujet
pour vous répondre la parole
au ministre de l'intérieur des Outre-mer
monsieur Gérald Darmanin
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Leroy comme vous nous sommes
évidemment préoccupés par les questions
migratoires comme partout en Europe 60%
de demandeurs d'asile par exemple ce
sont présentés à nos frontières et tous
les pays vous l'avez constaté quel que
soit les régimes politiques quel que
soit d'ailleurs le choix qu'ils ont fait
en matière migratoire ont les mêmes
difficultés je vous ferai un marquer
quand même c'était pas dans d'autres
questions que depuis le début de l'année
il y a moins de demandes d'asile
aujourd'hui qui en a eu depuis les trois
dernières années contrairement à ce qui
se passe chez nos voisins européens
puisqu'on est à 110 000 demandes d'asile
en moyenne sur le mois d'avril et
deuxièmement nous avons augmenté
l'exécution des eqtf et laisser passer
consulaire de plus de 20% depuis le 1er
janvier alors vous évoquez des
propositions nous sommes évidemment
heureux de les entendre nous n'avons pas
encore vu les deux textes proposés par
les LR nous avons compris qu'il nous est
pas totalement consensus avec les
centrices du Sénat qui vont déposer le
même je crois des textes mais nous
sommes là monsieur le sénateur pour
discuter avec l'ensemble de l'échiquier
politique et singulièrement avec la
majorité seattoriale puisque nous avons
déposé un texte et vous avez déjà
commencé à étudier en commission dans
les propositions DLR que nous avons lu
ce weekend il y a des choses tout à fait
concordantes la fin de la fin de la
double peine par exemple pour les
étrangers délinquants l'intégration
obligatoire par l'apprentissage du
français la simplification du droit
c'est-à-dire le rapport buffet nous
avons évidemment beaucoup de convergence
il y a aussi des différences monsieur
sénateur et notamment des divergences de
principes sur lesquels sans doute il
faut que nous débattions vous proposer
pour certains dispositions de sortir de
la Convention de Genève de 1951 de
sortir des traités de l'Union européenne
de sortir du Conseil de l'Europe de
sortir de la CEDH et si c'est tout à
fait vrai c'est une question importante
que ce frexit migratoire il faut
évidemment que nous puissions échanger
sur les propositions constitutionnelles
mais avouez que c'est ici nous faisons
un projet de lordinaire je veux redire
que à la demande de la première ministre
j'ai entrepris des nég ociations les
discussions avec le groupe LR du Sénat
avec les centrist avec tous les autres
groupes qui le souhaitent bien
évidemment pour je l'espère à l'automne
discuter de ce texte arrêté d'en parler
et de commencer d'être concret comme
vous l'a proposé le gouvernement
monsieur Leroy
oui monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur
nous savons que vous êtes un homme
d'écoute et que vous nous entendrez mais
ma question s'adressait à madame la
Première ministre
cette Français sur dix dénonce le trop
plein d'immigrés en France ils ont ces
Français des difficultés pour ce soigner
pour s'alimenter et pour vivre décemment
dans un climat d'insécurité ou la
violence devient quotidienne alors
madame la Première ministre donnez-leur
un peu d'espoir et agissez merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole est entre collègues angélique
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain
[Applaudissements]
deux solutions de lever un impôt sur les
10% les plus aisés pour financer la
transition écologique à vrai dire il n'y
a rien d'extravagant à imaginer qu'il
contribue à cet effort à la hauteur de
leur moyen en effet changer sa chaudière
et acquérir une voiture électrique n'est
pas à la portée de tous les Français et
pourtant la réduction conséquente en gaz
à effet de serre et donc l'habitabilité
de la planète profiteront à tous une
répartition équitable et non seulement
la moindre des choses mais relève d'une
justice sociale absolument indispensable
pour l'emport pour importer l'adhésion
et l'acceptabilité de tous nous avons
cessé depuis 2017 de vous proposer des
mesures fortes comme justement
l'instauration d'un ISF climatique en
pure perte comment envisagez-vous les
financements nécessaires au changement
radical qui s'imposent à nous
répondre la parole est communiste de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
du territoire Mitsubishi
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Préville
le rapport Pisani ferrique commandé par
le gouvernement il traite de beaucoup de
choses sur les 156 pages je note que
vous vous concentrez sur les trois qui
concernent la fiscalité vous auriez pu
souligner qu'il insiste sur la cohérence
de la stratégie de planification porte
présentée portée par la première
ministre et en citant très exactement
cette phrase du rapport
Pisany ferries et c'est le Mama fouzant
qui nous faut faire en disant ce que
nous n'avons pas fait en 30 ans c'est en
fait une citation d'Elisabeth borne qui
date d'octobre dernier au moment du
lancement du CNR sur le climat et la
biodiversité
je tiens à juste rappeler une ou deux
choses simples
dans ce domaine dans ce domaine
chacun serait bien inspiré d'insister
sur la hauteur de la marche sur le
chemin qui nous reste à parcourir plutôt
que de donner le sentiment que certains
avaient la solution parce que la vérité
c'est que depuis qu'il n'y a plus
d'écologiste au gouvernement le rythme
de baisse des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre a doublé
et une partie de ceux qui parlent passé
étaient les plus activistes et les plus
radicaux et qui nous incitait à sortir
du nucléaire à l'époque serait
aujourd'hui responsable si les
gouvernements successifs les avaient
écoutés d'une hausse des émissions qui
nous aurait considérablement éloigné de
là où nous en sommes aujourd'hui en
terme d'empreinte alors dans ce domaine
il y a à la fois un plan une stratégie
double l'atténuation présenter lundi
l'adaptation qui est nécessaire et qui
pour le coup ne dit indéni ni à
renoncement mais juste une manière de
regarder ensemble le fait que la
trajectoire n'est pas la bonne maille la
question du financement elle ne peut pas
être tabou mais dans la manière dont
elle est traitée par Monsieur Pisani
Ferri elle évoque plusieurs pistes
d'abord faire en sorte de réorienter les
dépenses nous sommes dans les champions
du monde en termes de prélèvement
obligatoire l'écologie ne doit pas être
le prétexte pour augmenter les impôts il
faut réorienter des dépenses et
réorienter de la fiscalité mais en aucun
cas ne se servir de ce prétexte pour
aller ajouter à une forme d'écologie qui
écartera une partie de nos concitoyens
alors qu'on a besoin de tout le monde
pour réussir compte tenu de l'ampleur du
défi
madame Préville
merci monsieur le ministre pour votre
réponse mais on ne peut pas se
satisfaire de la situation quelle que
soit ce qui a été engagé et c'est vrai
qu'il y a des choses qui ont été
engagées mais nous avons des inquiétudes
notamment sur les condensations
récurrentes pour une action climatique
pour non respect de la qualité de l'air
sur des paroles sur la pose
environnementale par exemple et sur très
concrètement dans les différentes lois
des régressions environnementales je
crois qu'effectivement je suis d'accord
avec vous mais sur ce que vous avez dit
sauf sur le fait que c'est une des
parties de la solution dont on ne peut
pas se passer le fait de d'avoir un
petit peu plus de justice sociale et
notamment sur l'acceptabilité
[Musique]
si monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'Intérieur la
commune de villegongy dans l'Indre 120
habitants a dû accueillir 30 000 de
Feurs à l'occasion du 30e technique il
est compréhensible que les jeunes se
retrouvent pour écouter de la musique
mais il est inacceptable que ce soit en
violation du droit de la propriété
inacceptable que ce soit en
contradiction avec un arrêté préfectoral
en l'absence d'organisateurs non
identifiables et non identifié en
l'absence tout simplement d'organisation
c'est donc la collectivité dans son
ensemble qui organisait la sécurité
physique et sanitaire des festivaliers
et de la population je veux saluer et
remercier les sapeurs-pompiers de
l'Indre les associations de la
protection civile les gendarmes les
équipes du Samu le personnel de santé
les services de l'État les collectivités
pour leur mobilisation 24 sur 24 durant
cinq jours
et c'est le contribuable qui paiera même
si et on peut le saluer des
confiscations ont eu lieu et cette
heureux mais au-delà du financier il est
urgent monsieur le ministre de
réinstaurer un cadre juridique ferme qui
permet d'anticiper et de responsabiliser
les festivaliers comme cela était le cas
avant 2016 l'île l'égalité entretient la
clandestinité et les festivals
continueront il existe depuis 30 ans
alors Monsieur le Ministre quelle mesure
comptez-vous prendre pour mettre fin à
l'impuissance de l'État devant ces
situations merci pour vous répondre la
parole est au ministre de l'intérieur
des Outre-mer monsieur Gérald Darmanin
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
sénateurs madame la sénatrice bellureux
merci d'abord des propos que vous êtes
nus pour les services publics qui soient
départementaux et locaux mais bien sûr
qui concerne les gendarmes et
singulièrement le préfet je sais qui
était mobilisé je l'ai eu de très
nombreuses fois au téléphone et ses
équipes préfectorales puisque vous avez
parfaitement raison il y a eu violation
du droit propriété par plus de 30000
personnes dans votre département un
rassemblement qui n'était pas déclaré
dès que nous avons eu quelques heures
avant l'information qui se rejoindrait
sur le site que vous avez évoqué dans
cette commune dont je voudrais
évidemment saluer les élus municipaux et
l'engagement qu'ils ont pu avoir malgré
les difficultés que vous avez dites et
les nuisances extrêmement fortes un
arrêté a été pris par Monsieur préfet
mais quand il y a 30000 personnes et
notamment des très jeunes gens qui se
rendent sur ce site j'ai pris la
responsabilité madame la sédatrice de ne
pas demander l'évacuation par la force
de ces jeunes qui avaient entre 15 et 30
ans pour la plupart d'entre eux et qui
évidemment dans ces conditions aurait pu
connaître des drames et je pense que la
protection de la jeunesse allait même
avant malheureusement les nuisances il
n'acceptable que l'on a constaté nous
avons en revanche décidé de contrôler
l'intégralité des personnes et vous
savez qu'il y a eu plus de 30000
contrôles vous l'avez dit vous mais
vous-même madame la sénatrice je vous
récidire que
13363 véhicules ont été entièrement
contrôlés faisant d'être un millier de
verbalisations ou d'interpellations pour
consommation de stupéfiants et où
consommation d'alcool que de très
nombreux de sortes de drogues ont été
saisis et je veux évidemment aussi
souligner que le préfet a fait des
articles 40 pour que bien sûr il puisse
y avoir poursuit après constitution de
qui est responsable de cette situation
et qui est l'organisateur de ces fêtes
dont on pense madame la sénatrice vous
et moi qu'il y a beaucoup d'argent
derrière tout ça également c'est sûr que
le droit actuel ne nous permet pas dans
les circonstances que vous avez évoquées
de pouvoir poursuivre les organisateurs
qui ne se déclarent pas il faut que nous
travaillons sans doute avec le Sénat
comme nous le faisons sur d'autres
sujets je pense évidemment
aux personnes qui s'installe
illégalement sur les aires d'accueil ou
les non heures d'accueil et il y a des
propositions de la part du Sénat le
gouvernement les regardera avec intérêt
en lien que le ministre des
collectivités locales Christophe Béchu
madame béluraux
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
ministre vous dites prêt au dialogue
pour pouvoir travailler sur cette
question je le redis en effet il faut
prévoir à l'avance des terrains adaptés
à ces rassemblements car gouverner ses
prévoir et il faut absolument que l'on
puisse ne puisse être de nouveau
confronté à une situation comme celle-ci
c'est-à-dire devant le fait accompli
la parole de notre collègue Nadia sur le
groupe sur le groupe de l'Union
centriste
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Agriculture mes chers
collègues la Cour des comptes a rendu
lundi un rapport sur l'avenir de
l'élevage bovin qui a causé sur tous les
bancs de vivre et actions et j'associe à
la mienne mes collègues Nathalie Goulet
Anne-Catherine Loisier et tous ceux qui
sont élus dans des terres d'élevage
bovin c'est-à-dire beaucoup le rendu
plomb vous a interpellé hier sur ce
sujet et vous lui avez répondu que vous
feriez fermement le choix de la
souveraineté nationale en la matière
mais le rapport en question préconise
clairement ceci mangez moins de viande
produire moins de viande et être ainsi à
l'équilibre et de cette manière en fait
on assume la souveraineté alors
pouvez-vous me confirmer monsieur le
ministre que c'est plus que vous voulez
pour l'élevage bovin que cette filière
d'excellence reste également
exportatrice conserve des capacités de
production supérieures à notre
autosuffisance je vous remercie
merci
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de l'Agriculture de
souveraineté alimentaire monsieur
Marcello merci Monsieur le monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs madame la sénatrice merci de
cette question
qui fait écho à plusieurs questions qui
m'ont été posées et qui font écho au
rapport de la Cour des comptes alors
d'abord je voudrais nous inviter
collectivement à lire la totalité du
rapport de la Cour des comptes et pas se
limiter à la page 9 et aux deux recueil
seul recommandations qui sont faites ça
serait justice que de l'orange je vais
en dire un mot le travail qui a été fait
par la Cour des comptes deuxième élément
là où on peut avoir et c'est normal
qu'on puisse avoir un débat et compris
avec la Cour des comptes c'est sur
l'équilibrage et le ce qui est proposé
par la Cour des comptes au fond c'est
une simple décroissance et une
décapitalisation qu'il faudrait forcer
pour répondre à des objectifs que par
ailleurs nous avons nécessité de tenir
qui sont des objectifs carbone alors
loin de moi l'idée d'abord de dire que
l'élevage ne doit pas prendre sa part
des efforts qu'il faut faire en termes
de décarbonation d'ailleurs ils se sont
mis sur ce chemin il y a des travaux de
recherche et d'innovation qui porte par
exemple sur l'alimentation qui va
permettre de tenir cette trajectoire
loin de moi l'idée de dire que la
consommation et que les évolutions de
consommation ne sont pas à tenir au
compte depuis 20 ou 30 ans vous savez
que structurellement il y a une baisse
de la consommation et que parfois on va
de vers la viande de la viande rouge
vers la viande blanche donc tout ça
c'est des choses qu'il faut regarder en
lucidité mais en revanche il y a quelque
chose qui est choquant c'est de proposer
comme ça parce que tu vas un éleveur
c'est ça fait partie des deux
recommandations c'est finalement de ne
plus être éleveur et ça c'est quelque
chose qui me semble-t-il n'est pas
acceptable d'abord parce que maintenant
ça n'est pas acceptable et parce que
deuxièmement sur ces territoires là en
particulier les bovins allaitants il n'y
a pas d'autres solutions que faire de
l'élevage ou rien et troisième élément
et d'ailleurs la Cour des comptes le dit
et ça j'invite à le regarder quand même
c'est comment on tient mieux compte des
autres services grand l'élevage que
celui d’abord de nos alimenter qui est
quand même un service important et on a
besoin je pense de réfléchir à ce que
sont les équilibres de viande et quel
est les matières de viande qu'on a
besoin de produire en France pour
répondre aux besoins de consommation
mais deuxièmement quelles sont les
aménités comme on dit qu'importe
l'élevage en particulier le maintien des
paysages ouverts la lutte contre les
incendies de forêts le maintien des
prairies la préservation de la
biodiversité tout ça ça a de la valeur
et donc tout ça il faut il faut en
rendre compte il faut aussi en rendre
compte dans les soutiens financiers qui
sont apportés à l'élevage et donc ne
caricaturons pas les uns les autres on a
besoin d'avoir une trajectoire carbone
au niveau national mais on a besoin
aussi de respecter les éleveurs dans
leur travail et dans les différents
utilités et à méditer qu'ils apportent à
la société française tout entière
madame ce logo oui je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre parce que vous me
prouvez que et je le savais déjà que
vous connaissez le monde de l'élevage
monsieur le Président le connaît très
bien également et moi un petit peu parce
qu'on avait l'impression que les experts
avaient pu aller se mettre dans une
prairie il peut mesurer d'un côté le
méthane émis et puis ce qui est capté
mais vous qui vous y connaissez vous
savez qu'une vache qui pète au Brésil ou
au Canada a exactement le même effet sur
la planète que si elle le fait en France
donc
[Applaudissements]
blague à part monsieur le ministre mais
vous avez compris ce que je voulais vous
dire dans les filets politiques
publiques maintenant et les experts de
la Cour des comptes doivent tenir compte
du bilan carbone dans les évaluations
des politiques publiques alors il va
falloir cesser de soutenir le pouvoir
d'achat des ménagères qui mettent dans
leur caddie des bananes ou du café qui
ont ce sont des produits qui ont un
bilan carbone déplorable
merci la parole de notre collègue Pascal
Alisa pour le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
manger des pommes un slogan bien connu
et sympathique il se trouve que l'on
peut aussi en boire et vous l'avez
compris je souhaiterais vous parler de
l'avenir du cidre français
l'activité cidrricole génère de nombreux
emplois représentent une filière
économique importante dans certains
territoires ruraux c'est notamment le
cas en Normandie mais aussi dans
d'autres régions françaises ces cidre
français correspondent à des productions
de qualité dont certains sous la belle
fabriqués sur la base de 100% de jus de
pomme ou de mou concentrés de pommes
fraîches par contre d'autres États
européens produisent une boisson
également appelée cidre à partir d'un
pourcentage de jus de pomme bien plus
faible 5 10 ou 25%, il s'ajoutent
ensuite de l'eau et du sucre en quantité
voire même des exhausteurs de goût
face à ces disparités la Commission
européenne souhaite semble-t-il
harmoniser la définition des cidres
commercialisés et les professionnels
s'inquiètent d'une harmonisation par le
bas qui serait préjudiciable à cette
filière par conséquent monsieur le
ministre ou en son réellement les
travaux sur ce sujet et comment le
gouvernement entendit-il préserver le
cidre français et nos spécificités au
niveau européen
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre d'agriculture et de
souveraineté alimentaire Monsieur
marfeno Merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur vous m'interrogez
sur la question de la filière cidre nous
sommes nombreux y compris la première
ministre être sensible à la question du
cidre
en bonormand que certains d'entre vous
sont il y a plusieurs sujets mais le
sujet principal que vous posez c'est la
question de l'harmonisation du droit
et de l'étiquetage au fond du cidre la
vérité c'est que la situation
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de règle
et que chacun peut dénommé cidre ou
Sider d'ailleurs dans certains pays des
produits qui ne sont pas avec les mêmes
degrés d'exigence le premier degré
d'exigence vous l'avez dit avec une
formule c'est que quand vous buvez du
cidre en France il est à 100% le produit
de pommes et il n'est pas mélangé à
autre chose et donc la position
la position qui est défendue par la
France au niveau européen dans cette
caisse contexte d'harmonisation c'est
bien une harmonisation qui tire tout le
monde vers le haut et qui fasse en sorte
qu'on essaie de sortir de la situation
dans laquelle on est puisque nous sommes
la frontière ouverte ou des gens peuvent
se réclamer de l'appellation enfin de
l'appellation de la dénomination cible
sans en être vraiment et qui permettent
de mieux valoriser la qualité du cidre
français en particulier de la région que
vous connaissez bien et donc c'est là
dessus qu'on essaie de travailler avec
la commission la résolution de sujet
européen et c'est toujours le même à la
vérité c'est pas le sujet n'est pas
d'avoir raison défendre une position de
trouver le sujet c'est trouver une
majorité
et d'arriver à convaincre les collègues
donc c'est le travail qu'on fait
actuellement au niveau européen pour
faire en sorte qu'on reconnaisse bien la
qualité du cidre en ce qu'il est le
composé à 100% de pommes et que pour le
reste on peut appeler ça comme on veut
mais qu'on peut pas l'appeler cidre si
on est dans le registre d'une
harmonisation européenne quels sont les
éléments que je peux vous dire
aujourd'hui on a un processus qui est
assez long mais pour la France n'est pas
acceptable que ce soit quelque chose qui
viendrait dégrader la qualité du cidre
français parce que elle est reconnue au
travers par les Français les reconnus au
delà des frontières et donc on a besoin
de le mieux la faire reconnaître et donc
l'étiquetage est un élément important
monsieur ELISA
merci Monsieur le Ministre effectivement
la Commission européenne précise que ce
rapport je cite ne conduira pas
forcément à une proposition législative
or nous savons bien que en fait la pomme
ne tombe jamais bien loin de l'arbre
donc la méfiance et la vigilance doivent
être de mise car on connaît le zèle de
certains normateurs et on connaît aussi
leur capacité à prendre le bon sens à
contre-pied vous l'avez compris monsieur
le ministre on compte sur vous merci
la parole est à notre collègienne
chanterelle pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicains
merci merci monsieur le Président mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse au
ministre de l'éducation nationale le 1er
mars dernier à l'initiative de notre
groupe nous organisions dans cette
hémicycle un débat sur la mixité sociale
à l'école le constat implacable était
partagé sur l'ensemble de nos bancs
alors qu'en moyenne la proportion
d'élèves issus des milieux défavorisés
et de 42,6% dans le public elle est
seulement de 18% dans le privé ces
écarts ne cessent de se creuser depuis
20 ans nous allons vers un système
scolaire à deux vitesses une école
privée réservée aux enfants privilégiés
et une école publique pour tous les
autres voilà le véritable séparatisme à
l'oeuvre dans notre pays à l'occasion de
ce débat du 1er mars le ministre de
l'éducation nationale disait je cite
parce que l'argent public finance
l'enseignement privé sous contrat à
hauteur de 73% je le rappelle il est
normal exiger de ce dernier qu'il
favorise aussi la mixité des élèves il
parlait alors de moyens de pression sur
les établissements privés sous contrat
notamment en modulant leur subventions
sous forme de bonus malus mais aussi en
juin sur les allocations de poste il
avait même abordé la question de la
sectorisation dont vous estimiez qu'elle
avait donné des résultats probants nous
attendions donc avec impatience des
annonces fortes de la part du
gouvernement pour mettre fin à cette
ségrégation scolaire qui mine notre
pacte social et fait de notre pays un
des plus inégalitaires de l'OCDE le
protocole d'accord que vous avez dévoilé
le 17 mai après deux reports affections
il ne comporte ni exigence contraignante
ni modulation des subventions des
allocations de poste ni bonus malus et
encore moins de sectorisation nous
comprenons donc que ce gouvernement qui
défend toujours les plus privilégiés
n'agira pas pour plus de mixité scolaire
quand prendrez-vous la mesure du
problème en agissant fortement pour des
mesures contraignantes pour mettre la
mixité scolaire dans les écoles de
France
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
mini déléguée chargée de l'enfilement et
de la formation professionnelle madame
la ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Yann chanterelle tout d'abord
je vous prie de bien vouloir excuser
monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
nationale Papé Ndiaye qui est retenu sur
le prix non au harcèlement vous le savez
notre ambition et d'avoir une action
résolument concrète de réduction de la
ségrégation sociale de nos
établissements scolaires nous ne pouvons
nous satisfaire en effet de la situation
actuelle l'écart de composition sociale
entre élèves des établissements du
public mais aussi entre établissement du
public et du privé se creuse depuis les
années 2000 et vous l'avez rappelé pour
y remédier le ministre de l'éducation
nationale a d'abord voulu agir sur les
établissements publics qui je le
rappelle rassemble 90% des élèves c'est
pourquoi il a demandé à l'ensemble des
recettes de s'emparer de différents
leviers avec pour objectif de faire
progresser de 20% la mixité sociale dans
les établissements publics d'ici à 2027
en ce qui concerne l'enseignement privé
le ministre a toujours souhaité
privilégier la concertation à la
contrainte sur ce sujet d'autant que la
préoccupation de la mixité sociale et
scolaire et plus que partager par
l'enseignement catholique et qu'ils ont
très vite montré leur volonté de
s'engager sur ce sujet et c'est bien
grâce à cette concertation fruit d'un
travail de plusieurs mois que nous avons
pu signer mercredi dernier un a
protocole d'engagement commun avec le
secrétaire général de l'Enseignement
Catholique cela n'avait pas été fait
depuis plus de 30 ans et je crois qu'il
faut le souligner ce protocole il
prévoit notamment de suivre avec des
indicateurs précis les effets de ces
actions à travers l'évolution de la
mixité sociale et scolaire au sein des
établissements privés sous contrat je
crois que c'est une avancée importante
qu'il faut pouvoir souligner vous voyez
pour que cette politique en faveur de
l'égalité des chances pour que tous les
élèves réussissent nous pensons qu'il
convaincre et non contraindre
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Pierre Charron pour le groupe les
républicains merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
nationale c'est toujours désagréable de
s'adresser à un absent en 2022 pour
faire face à la hausse continue des
atteintes à la laïcité vous avez élaboré
un plan depuis la publication de ce plan
que constate-t-on au mois d'octobre
dernier le nombre de signalements avait
atteint 720 une hausse de 130% par
rapport au mois précédent au mois de
mars il est encore été passé les 500 cas
monsieur le ministre comme vous l'avez
déclaré la hausse du mois d'octobre est
liée à la commémoration de l'assassinat
de Samuel Paty mais 500 cas du mois de
mars correspondent à une remontée chaque
année au moment du Ramadan dites-vous
aux explications très catégoriques n'ont
d'ailleurs réussi qu'une seule chose
soulevez une polémique et notamment par
la Grande Mosquée de Paris
quant au mois d'avril dans l'académie de
Paris les données qui ont été
communiquées par vos services ne sont
pas bonnes je vous laisse le soin de les
annoncer ce sont des chiffres les plus
élevés depuis la rentrée de septembre il
faut aussi y ajouter les signalements
d'antisémitisme qui eux ne relèvent pas
d'atteinte à la laïcité mais les
procédures pénales au statistiques
sont-elles fiables et surtout sont
inutiles la réponse est non vos chiffres
sont manifestement sous-estimés pour le
principal syndicat des personnels de
direction des collèges et lycées les
tenues litigieuses les contestations
d'enseignement ou même les difficultés
en santé scolaire ne font pas l'objet de
signalement de manière systématique vos
statistiques sont inutiles la réponse
est encore non
ces chiffres ne traduisent en aucune
réponse aux attaques entre la laïcité
l'échelle d'établissement se sentent
bien seuls ils attendent des réponses
concrètes il vous demande des outils
réglementaires pour mieux gérer ces
situations
votre absence de fermeté sur tous les
sujets maintient la porte ouverte à
toutes les revendications communautaires
la question est simple allez vous
monsieur le ministre vous contentez
moins après moi de recenser les
atteintes à laïcité et de les commenter
où allez-vous enfin donner aux
responsables d'établissement des
directives claires merci
pour vos réponses la parole est à la
ministre délégués chargés de
l'enseignement madame Grandjean
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Charron afin de répondre à
votre question je souhaite rappeler
plusieurs actions engagées par Monsieur
le Ministre de l'Éducation nationale et
de la jeunesse qui je le rappelle est
absent pour cause de remise de prix sur
le l'enjeu de la lutte contre le
harcèlement le ministre de l'éducation
nationale et de la jeunesse à demander
une publication des chiffres mensuels
des atteintes à la laïcité que vous avez
rappelé ces chiffres sont désormais
visibles disponibles sur le site du
ministère de l'Éducation nationale pour
plus de transparence plus de suivi et
organiser cette mobilisation pour la
lutte contre les atteintes à la laïcité
le ministre de l'éducation nationale a
souhaité là où c'est nécessaire renforcé
des équipes valeur de la République et à
élargi la formation de tous les
personnels de l'Éducation nationale je
voudrais le rappeler le plan que le
ministre a annoncé en novembre 202 a
déjà permis à 300 000 personnels
d'éducation dont 5000 chefs
d'établissement et adjoints à être
formés sur le sujet je crois que cette
formation est absolument concrète elle
permet aux autres d'être mieux
accompagnés mieux avec des outils qui
leur permettent de lutter efficacement
contre ces atteintes à la laïcité le
ministre de l'éducation nationale a
également renforcé les mesures du site
disciplinaire en cas d'atteinte au
principe de laïcité en diffusant une
circulaire très claire au chef
d'établissement qui jusqu'à présent
restait dans le flou quant aux
procédures à mettre en oeuvre le
ministre de l'éducation nationale a
également institut de finalisé le
conseil des sages et de la laïcité en
nommant enfant ses membres 5 ans après
la création de cette entité les membres
historiques ont d'ailleurs tous été
confirmés dans ces fonctions je voudrais
monsieur le sénateur que nous puissions
partager l'engagement du gouvernement et
du ministre de l'éducation nationale
sans faille pour lutter contre ces
atteintes à la laïcité je crois que
au-delà des mots les actions sont les
plus fortes l'accompagnement des
personnels l'engagement bien sûr de cela
mais aussi l'organisation des mesures
disciplinaires qui sont donc passées par
voie réglementaires récemment encore
merci
vous le souhaitez vous avez quelques
secondes merci la parole est à notre
collègue Brigitte l'herbier pour le
groupe les républicains
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier le ministre monsieur le ministre
de l'Intérieur mes chers collègues
dimanche matin au commissariat de
Roubaix une équipe de policiers sur la
relève de nuit appel de détresse d'une
jeune fille cette mission est confiée à
une jeune patrouille de policier
recueillir cette mineure présumée violée
pour la protéger et la conduire à
l'hôpital cette précipitation au service
de l'autre sera la dernière pour Paul
Steven et Manon ce matin-là ils sont
partis de chez eux heureux ils ne savait
pas qu'il ne reverrai jamais leurs
proches à Roubaix il y a une vraie
solidarité entre la police nationale
municipale les pompiers c'est une ville
méritante
à l'École nationale de police de Roubaix
la directrice la commissaire kitchenko
apprend au nouvelle recrues les
difficultés de la profession il faudra
beaucoup de professionnels et de rigueur
pour exercer ce métier Manon stagiaire
était prête à entrer dans cette grande
famille
Kader Haroun le commissaire principal de
Roubaix dirige le commissariat avec
bienveillance et fermeté
il leur a dit combien la police était un
vrai ascenseur social pour tous ceux qui
ont à cœur de défendre les valeurs de la
République monsieur le ministre vous
êtes fier de vos hommes vous avez bien
raison de les défendre la mort de ces
trois jeunes policiers de Roubaix
prouvent encore une fois les risques de
ce métier ils ont été tués par un
chauffard
ivre sous l'emprise de stupéfiants
roulant en grande vitesse à contresens
de police leur décès est un choc immense
pour tout leur collègues leurs proches
le nord et plus largement pour notre
pays tout entier ce qui s'est produit
est inacceptable au nom de tous mes
collègues j'adresse mes sincères
condoléances aux familles aux proches
des jeunes aujourd'hui on se recueille
monsieur le ministre que pouvons-nous
faire des deux mains pour stopper ce
fléau
je me dois de vous demander monsieur le
ministre si le Gouvernement entend
prendre des mesures pour intensifier la
lutte contre les conducteurs dangereux
sous emprise de drogue ou d'alcool et si
l'envisage de durcir les peines encourus
par leur secteur ou autre pour vous
répondre la parole et comme ils disent
de l'intérieur des Outre-mer monsieur
Darmanin
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
créatrice Brigitte clerbier merci des
mots très touchants que vous avez eu
pour ces trois jeunes policiers du
commissariat de Roubaix un commissariat
parmi les plus difficiles de France qui
compte énormément de moyens à la hauteur
sans doute du dur métier que font les
policiers les personnes administratifs
de ce site qui vous le savez vous avez
cité le commissaire Haroun fait
l'honneur de la police nationale moi je
veux d'abord dire aux familles de ces
policiers de mal prison de la réplique
le rendra officiellement hommage à
l'École nationale de police de Roubaix
qu'ils font l'honneur à 24 à 25 à 26 ans
de la France du service public et nous
pensons tous à leur famille à ce petit
enfant d'un an qui aurait eu un an dans
les jours qui viennent et à cette jeune
femme qui est enceinte d'un de ces
jeunes policiers et c'est assassin celui
qui était dans la voiture averse parce
qu'il faut utiliser les mots qui
comptent à tuer
non seulement trois destins mais
abaisser l'intégralité de la police
nationale
alors après l'hommage il y a évidemment
réfléchir madame la sénatrice et avec
d'autres faits divers parce que ce n'est
pas le seul trop de chauffard trop
d'assassins tu sur les routes sous
l'emprise de stupéfiants et d'alcool
nous a travaillons avec le garde des
sceaux pour évidemment pouvoir réussir à
limiter un drame nous avons proposé le
retrait des 12 points pour ceux qui
consomment sur stupéfiants c'est une
mesure réglementaire le garde des soins
proposé de renommer
cette homicide comme un homicide routier
c'est attendu il y a beaucoup de
propositions d'ailleurs de votre
assemblée elle est surtout les bancs je
peux vous assurer que sous l'autorité de
la première ministre avec Monsieur le
gardeesseau et en espérant que d'autres
drames sont invités par le travail que
font les policiers légendaires tous les
jours sur les routes pour éviter que ces
chauffards de continuer à tuer nous
sommes à disposition du Parlement et du
Sénat et de vous-même pour pouvoir
travailler dans ce sens en la mémoire de
ces trois jeunes policiers je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le ministre
nous avons terminé avec les questions
gouvernement je vous rappelle que les
prochaines questions ont lieu le
mercredi 31 mai à 15h je vais suspendre
la séance elle sera reprise à 16h30 pour
l'examen de quatre conventions
internationales puis du projet de loi
visant à donner à la douane les moyens
de faire face aux nouvelles menaces la
séance est suspendue
[Musique]
voilà pour cette séance des questions
d'activité au gouvernants que vous avez
pu suivre en direct et en intégralité
sur l'antenne de Public Sénat parmi les
temps forts cette semaine on voit le
retour de cette polémique autour du
projet de loi immigration déjà un
reporté à deux reprises depuis le début
de l'année le sénateur LR des
Alpes-Maritimes Henri Leroy à des pins
une situation où la France va mal dit-il
l'échec du gouvernement a contrôlé
l'immigration et pas tant écouter le
sénateur
le coût économique de cette immigration
est un sujet que le nom peut plus éluder
l'aide médicale d'État continue de
progresser de plus de 12% cette année
pour atteindre un point culminant à 1,2
milliards d'euros et l'accueil des
immigrés pèsent de plus en plus sur nos
finances publiques le coût social de
l'Immigration et de moins en moins
acceptable la loi n'est pas respectée
les au qtf ne sont pas exécutés sans
oublier le communautarisme et la
violence qui congrène notre société
touchant bien souvent les Français les
plus modestes c'est Gérald Darmanin qui
a répondu au sénateur LR le minisateur
qui est chargé en de reprendre les
négociations sur le projet de loi
immigration il a évoqué aussi les deux
propositions de loi venues des LR
d'abord en parlant rapidement des points
d'accord avec ces deux textes puis des
nombreux désaccords écouter Gérald
Darmanin il y a aussi des différences
monsieur le sénateur et notamment les
divergences de principes
sur lequel sans doute il faut que nous
débattions vous proposez pour certaines
dispositions de sortir de la Convention
de Genève de 1951 de sortir des traités
de l'Union européenne de sortir du
Conseil de l'Europe de sortir de la CEDH
et si c'est tout à fait vrai c'est une
question importante que ce frexit
migratoire il faut évidemment que nous
puissions échanger sur les propositions
constitutionnelles mais avouer que c'est
ici nous faisons un projet de loi
ordinaire voilà tellement on verra
maintenant comment va se passer l'examen
des propositions de loi venu DLR et
également quelle sera la présentation du
texte fait en juillet ce projet de loi
immigration voulu par le gouvernement
merci merci merci beaucoup pour cette
analyse et cette décryptage de la séance
Quentin on vous retrouve tout à l'heure
tout au long de ce débrief mais pour
leur on revient salle des conférences
rejoindre Alexandre Poussard avec la
ministralie aspirma le Bodo notamment
pour revenir et bien sûr les agressions
des soignants dans les hôpitaux après il
y a notamment qu'une infirmière a été
tuée cette semaine effectivement Tom et
il y a eu quelques mots dommage de la
part du président du Sénat et de la
première ministre hommage à cette
infirmière qui est décédée à l'hôpital
de Reims en début de semaine madame la
ministre cela met en lumière le problème
de la violence faite aux soignants avec
une hausse de ce type de violence cette
année une hausse de 23% vous travaillez
sur le sujet depuis le mois de février
vous allez faire des annonces le 1er
juin vous attendez la publication d'un
rapport sur ce fléau qu'elles vont être
les grandes lignes de votre stratégie
pour lutter contre ces violences tout
d'abord permettez-moi de redire notre
soutien à la communauté des soignants
c'est bien toute la communauté des
soignants qui est en deuil ce midi la
première ministre et le ministre de la
santé était à l'hôpital Pompidou nous
étions à San expo avec le président de
la FHF Stanislas glinerini et Isabelle
Rome pour une minute de silence en
mémoire de l'infirmière décédée
tragiquement la violence faite aux
professionnels de santé c'est
malheureusement un phénomène dont nous
aurons d'années en année la progression
dès l'arrivée dans ce ministère j'ai
souhaité faire de de cette lutte contre
les violences faites aux professionnels
de santé un axe de notre politique avec
l'appui de la première ministre et du
ministre de la Santé une mission a été
lancée le rapport devait nous être nous
remis le 30 mai l'accident est arrivé
hier et donc nous devons un peu répondre
à ces questions 450 propositions ont été
faites à Jean-Christophe Masteron et à
Nathalie nion qui sont les deux
personnes missionnées nous travaillons
autour pour l'instant de trois axes tout
d'abord sensibiliser la population
expliquer que la tolérance zéro envers
les soignants à l'hôpital en ét et en
ville la tolérance zéro ça commence par
les agressions verbales la tolérance
zéro former les soignants à la gestion
de l'agressivité c'est quelque chose qui
doit se développer toute la problème
autour de la sécurité même des bâtiments
la sécurité préventionnelle et puis
accompagner les victimes dans leur
démarche mais aussi les accompagner dans
le suivi psychologique et puis bien sûr
travailler dans le cadre de convention
avec la police et avec la justice autour
de ses axes nous ferons des propositions
très pragmatiques mais je tiens aussi à
le rappeler qu'il faut distinguer la
violence structurelle due à ce que nous
constatons la violence envers les élus
la violence envers les pompiers envers
les policiers mais aussi malheureusement
ce qui s'est passé à Reims la violence
plus imprévisible puisque dû à une
personne instable qui souffrait de
troubles psychiatre vous parliez de
tolérance zéro est-ce que vous envisagez
une et bien gravation des sanctions
pénales justement sur les violences
faites aux soignants d'après les
propositions qui ont été faites je le
redis à nos deux
à deux personnes responsables de la
mission je crois que
ulégard à ce qui s'est fait pour les
élus et que qui était
appelé la semaine la semaine dernière
par ma collègue Dominique Faure la
question d'une d'une spécialisation
pénale pour ces violences faites aux
professionnels de santé sera sans doute
mis sur la table et nous devrons
travailler peut-être avec les forces de
justice sur cet aspect particulier je le
redis la tolérance zéro nous devons
protéger ceux qui nous protège nous
devons protéger ceux qui nous soignent
une question qui va être donc envisagée
en ces sanctions pénales vous parlez
aussi des bâtiments des hôpitaux
aujourd'hui c'est quoi le problème c'est
qu'on entre trop facilement dans un
hôpital comme dans un moulin on entre
parfois trop facilement dans un hôpital
parfois même les cabinets médicaux des
médecins généralistes qui sont dans leur
cabinet parfois parce que maintenant on
prend des rendez-vous par internet sans
secrétaire sont ouverts et donc on peut
se mettre en danger je crois qu'il nous
faut comme la transition écologique
devient dans le cahier des charges de
nos bâtiments faire de la sécurité un
argument fort
des cahiers des charges des bâtiments à
construire mais aussi de les bâtiments à
rénover pour protéger notamment les
soignants qui vont au domicile de
certains patients il y a une proposition
qui est faite de leur donner des
bracelets ça peut être repris là aussi
il est important d'aller sur le terrain
ce que je fais l'hôpital Bichat très
très en amont pris cette problématique
c'est surprenant d'aller dans les
urgences à l'hôpital Bichat il y a
personne dans les couloirs la gestion à
la fois des patients mais à la fois des
personnes qui accompagnent et faites et
on voit personne dans les couloirs il y
a pas de il y a pas de violence parce
que on protège les soignants et lorsque
je me suis déplacé au mois de mai à
Chambéry j'ai pu constater que les
bracelets qui étaient à disposition des
médecins qui allaient domicile
permettait de de les géolocaliser et
donc d'aller vers eux si jamais il y
avait un problème je crois que là aussi
c'est un moyen de protéger les personnes
qui vont à domicile les médecins mais
aussi les infirmières qu'il ne faut pas
oublier et les ambulanciers dont on
oublie parfois qu'ils vont chercher des
patients à domicile bien sûr tous les
professionnels de santé merci beaucoup
d'être venu au micro public c'est NON
MERCI MERCI BEAUCOUP Alexandre et on va
continuer le débrief de ces questions au
gouvernement puisque
Alexandre vous êtes à présent avec le
président du groupe Union centriste au
Sénat également président de l'UDI Hervé
Marseille et il va notamment être
question et bien de ces propositions de
loi immigration il y en a du côté de LR
il y en a aussi du côté décentrisme
effectivement dans un instant on va
parler de ses propositions sur les
migrations mais d'abord Hervé Marseille
j'aimerais évoquer avec vous une
question importante qui a été évoquée
cet après-midi sur le financement de la
transition écologique l'Agence France
stratégie propose un ISF climatique le
gouvernement qui avait commandé ce
rapport dit finalement non pas dose
d'impôts vous vous le préconisez vous le
souhaitez je pense que effectivement il
va falloir trouver de l'argent mais on
peut pas taper au même endroit pour tous
les problèmes l'année dernière
sur le périphér on avait posé la
question
de la taxation des profits exceptionnels
mais c'était pour l'énergie
après on a parlé des retraites on nous a
dit il faut un impôt exceptionnel
également mais alors qu'il fallait
trouver des ressources pérennes et
maintenant on dit il faut de l'impôt
pour la transition écologique donc oui
pour trouver des ressources mais il faut
savoir à quel endroit on le prend on
peut pas le prendre sur les entreprises
on peut pas le prendre pour la dette on
peut donc il faut un impôt qui soit
ciblé et pas sur des classes moyennes
alors il faut travailler le sujet et
être très prudent parce qu'on peut pas
taxer pour tout et pour tout le monde
alors justement on en parlait cet
après-midi et bien le ministre de
l'intérieur a été interrogé par l'un de
vos collègues les républicains notamment
sur les propositions de loi qui sont
depuis ce week-end par les républicains
pour mieux réguler l'immigration il y a
une proposition de loi constitutionnelle
qui propose de déroger à certains
traités internationaux et à certains
engagements européens Charles de
Darmanin a l'air contre il a parlé cet
après-midi de frexit migratoire vous
reprenez cette expression
écoutez moi je trouve pertinent et
positif que les républicains expriment
leur position c'est bien parce que tout
le monde parle de ces sujets mais on
voit assez peu de propositions écrites
donc il va y avoir une proposition
écrite nous nous allons faire nos
propositions également ils seront
différentes à l'évidence nous sommes
européens et nous sommes très attentifs
au cadre européen la Constitution on
peut la modifier mais ça prend du temps
il faut les trois cinquième je vous
rappelle donc on va essayer de trouver
des solutions et des propositions qui
soient plus faisable et plus rapidement
quels seront les grandes lignes des
propositions centristes sur les
migration oh bon il y a une partie qui
reprend ce qui a déjà été votée je vous
rappelle qu'un texte a été voté par la
commission des lois et c'est sûrement je
n'en sais rien mais à partir de ce texte
que les discussions pourront peut-être
reprendre dans quelques semaines vous
pensez que vous trouverez un accord avec
les sénateurs de la républicains
notamment sur le réseau il y a pas de
raison on peut être on fait ça tous les
jours ici donc on pourra trouver des
compromis en tous les cas je l'espère
merci beaucoup Hervé Marseille d'être
venu à notre micro et dans un instant on
va accueillir votre homologue du groupe
les républicains Bruno Retailleau oui
brun
o effectivement
il sort du traité pourquoi parce que le
traité dit dans son article 4 alinéa 2
la sécurité nationale et du ressort de
la responsabilité exclusive des nations
donc là où il y a pas de compétences
européenne il peut pas y avoir de
primauté du droit européen donc il
arrive à des juges de se tromper il
arrive à des juges de s’écarter de la
loi ou du traité il faut trouver un
mécanisme démocratique pour dire
attention alerte rouge d'ailleurs
l'Allemagne l'a fait la cour de carlsruh
la Cour suprême allemande l'a fait
solennellement il y a deux ans au sujet
de la politique monétaire de la Banque
centrale d'Allemagne est-ce que les
Allemands veulent sortir de l'Europe
bien sûr que non donc nous on n'a pas
être les
idiots utiles vous voyez d'une forme
d'européisme qui transgresse un servante
de frontières juridique je pense que on
doit défendre nos intérêts fondamentaux
est-ce que les LR ne sont pas en train
de devenir plus souverainiste que
robéistes
non encore une fois qu'est-ce qui vaut
c'est le traité tout le traité quand une
jurisprudence s'écarte du traité quand
par exemple le Conseil constitutionnel
sur les ordonnances nous dit oh c'est
pas très grave qu'elle soit paratifié
total il y a pratiquement plus
gratification d'ordonnance alors que
l'article 38 modifié par la révision
constitutionnelle du collège Sarkozy dit
qu'il faut précédemment qu'elle soit
ratifiée il y a un problème il s'écarte
du texte on n'est plus dans
l'interprétation donc Montesquieu disait
des juges il faut qu'il reste les
bouches de la loi et attention à ce que
les juges ne deviennent pas à la place
du législateur des producteurs de droits
qui s'éloigneraient des traités ou
simplement des textes alors avec se
tient Olivier Marleix vous avez écrit
une lettre au président de la République
pour lui demander d'organiser un
référendum sur l'immigration est-ce
qu'il vous a répondu est-ce que vous
pensez qui qui va prendre quand même ce
risque de faire un référendum sur une
question sensible je vais vous dire
c'est parce qu'elle est sensible qu'il
faut faire un référendum faut pas la
laisser à d'autres qu'au peuple français
parce que d'autres parties plus extrêmes
choisissent et prospère sur cette
question là il y a pas un autre
phénomène qui est au temps bouleversé la
société française depuis un demi siècle
sans que les Français n'étaient jamais
consultés moi je souhaite que dans
l'article 11 on puisse consulter les
Français c'est-à-dire qu'en clair un
référendum puisse avoir lieu sur le
sujet de l'immigration pour ça faut
réviser la Constitution mais je pense
que où on est dans une démocratie où on
ne l'est plus je pense que à l'origine
du malaise démocratique c'est que les
gens pensent trop souvent que leur
bulletin de vote vaut pour rien du tout
il faut les remettre au coeur de notre
démocratie dernière question sur le
débat au Sénat qui aura lieu notamment
sur vos propositions de l'olr sur
l'immigration pour l'instant les
centristes ont l'air contre ils
craignent un texte qui est trop à droite
quelle concession vous pouvez leur faire
pour essayer d'avoir une majorité au
Sénat sur sur ces textes mais vous savez
regardez le texte qui est sorti
d'ailleurs texte du Gouvernement tel
qu'il est sorti voté par la commission
des Lois du Sénat
on a l'arrêt de l'aide médicale d'État
on a une transformation profonde du
titre pour des séjours pour les
étrangers malades pour que les charges
reviennent pas la sécurité sociale zéro
français mais qu'il en supportent les
charges on a le principe des quotas donc
on est capable d'avancer très loin c'est
ça la négociation mais je pense que ils
sont centrés c'est nous on est de droite
il faut surtout pas que on abaisse si
j'ose dire le les exigences de nos
propres convictions au mieux
s'additionner plutôt que de fusionner
dans quelque chose ou ce qui perdrait
c'est précisément le sel des convictions
merci beaucoup Bruno Retailleau c'est
avocat merci beaucoup Alexandre tout de
suite on passe au débrief de cette
séance de questions au gouvernement et
pour cela j'accueille sur ce plateau
Yann chanterai le bonjour donateur
socialiste représentant les Français
établis hors de France face à vous
Emmanuel Capu bonjour vous êtes
sénateurs les indépendants de
Maine-et-Loire vice-président de la
commission des finances et enfin Jérôme
pas cher bonjour c'est Nathan LR de
l'Oise et secrétaire de la commission
des finances Jérôme Bachar on vient
d'entendre Bruno Retailleau à l'instant
qui dit bon on a trouvé des accords avec
les centrices quand on a commencé à
examiner le projet de Loi de
l'immigration pourquoi vous vous en
tenez pas là finalement pourquoi aller
sur une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle pourquoi en demander
plus demander ce référent d'un de ses
côtés etc
j'ai lu les journaux
et le président de la République il y a
8 jours dit dans votre cas de
l'immigration quand elle a l'air seront
d'accord
et bien les LR on dit chiche on prend du
Assemblée nationale le parti Sénat un
texte de texte comme voilà nous sommes
d'accord la balle dans le terrain
d'Emmanuel Macron cela fait plus d'un an
en vérité que ce texte est avancé il a
été annoncé par Gérald Darmanin pour
septembre
puis après un peu plus tard puis
à l'hiver puis au printemps puis elle
était puis elle est AUTOMNE bon voilà
c'est les quatre saisons de je n'ai pas
de politique et nous nous avons une
c'est un front durcissement de la
politique migratoire que vous proposez
c'est à prendre ou à laisser ou est-ce
que c'est une base de négociation sur le
sujet constitutionnel façon nous n'avons
pas totalement la main donc nous savons
parfaitement donc mais on a montré
la capacité donc on va pas non plus
s'inventer des pouvoirs qu'on a pas ça
c'est le propre comme le disait
justement vous ne retaillou d'un certain
nombre d'instances qui commencent à
parler de sujets sur lesquels ils n'ont
pas de compétences et n'ayant pas la
compétence en vérité il se délégitimise
et notamment parce que le peuple
français les peuples européens ne les
ont pas légitimer pour cela et ça c'est
très grave parce que cela fait naître un
sentiment anti-européen qu'on veut être
pour l'Europe nous sommes pour l'Europe
il faut que ce soit les textes votés par
le peuple
et rien que cela pas au delà en tout cas
et bien tout à l'heure dans l'hémicycle
Gérald Darmanin a eu l'analyse de votre
proposition il a dénoncé un frexit
migratoire on va l'écouter tout à
l'heure dans l'hémicycle
il y a aussi des différences monsieur
sénateur et notamment des divergences de
principes sur lesquels sans doute il
faut que nous débattions vous proposez
pour certaines dispositions de sortir de
la Convention de Genève de 1951 de
sortir des traités de l'Union européenne
de sortir du Conseil de l'Europe de
sortir de la CEDH et si c'est tout à
fait vrai c'est une question importante
que ce frexit migratoire il faut
évidemment que nous puissions échanger
sur les propositions constitutionnelles
mais avouez que c'est ici nous faisons
un projet loi ordinaire Emmanuel qui a
pu la majorité présidentielle a besoin
des voix LR pour faire adopter le projet
de loi les propositions de leur projet
de loi immigration est-ce que vous êtes
prêt à aller sur ce terrain
je sais pas la question la question
effectivement c'est que je pense qu'il
faut qu'on ait qu'on aille au bout d'un
projet de loi immigration parce que je
crois qu'on est tous autour de la table
convaincu qui a quand même une
difficulté sur ce sujet là y compris je
pense
je peux pas m'avancer pour la gauche
mais je pense quand même que
il y a quand même un large consensus sur
lequel il y a une difficulté sur les
migrations en France après c'est vrai
que il faudra bien trouver un accord
aussi politique avec une majorité large
moi je
vais constaté quand même qu'on trouve
qu'il y avait un texte qui avait été
déposé par le Gouvernement qui avance
devant la commission des lois du siècle
qui était issu en grande partie du
rapport du président de la commission
des lois de François Noël buffet s'il
est LR se mettent d'accord on a vu au
dernier sur le débat sur les retraites
c'était pas évident qu'il y avait pas
qu'une seule ligne il compte entre les
députés eux-mêmes et entre les députés
là
que il y a un accord au sein du parti LR
tant mieux si ça peut faire des
propositions c'est très bien faut pas
non plus que ça soit de l'assurance cher
qui soit qui soit une on peut débattre
de tout ça me paraît compliqué ça paraît
compliqué de réformer la constitution ça
me paraît parce que c'est déjà trouver
une majorité c'est compliqué trouver une
majorité des 3/5 pour modifier la
Constitution ça me paraît
objectif non c'est bon c'est le bon
terme improbable
faut pas que ça soit non plus des effets
d'annonce donc mais en revanche si on
peut trouver une solution
j'y suis tout à fait favorable
on va pas vous faire parler avant que
vous ayez parlé bah mon regard c'est
déjà qu'il faut pas être dupe par
rapport à ce qui est proposé par le
groupe LR on n'est pas encore sorti
d'une séquence de mobilisation contre la
réforme des retraites qui a mobilisé
très fortement votre corps pour ça que
d'ailleurs ça pas pu être voté à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est parce que
elle a été divisée au sein même de son
groupe à l'Assemblée nationale donc on
tente de faire une sorte de diversion
sur un autre sujet de manière très
démagogique parce que ce qui est visé
par diversion
dans un premier temps de faire diversion
parce que c'est eux qui propose de
textes et ils vont faire diversion en
Dracy en dragon clairement un électorat
qui est électorat de l'extrême droite de
l'extrême droite c'est ça les clins
d'oeil qui sont appuyés vis-à-vis d'un
électrode c'est l'électorat de l'extrême
droite et moi
ça on va faire une chose
moi-même j'étais un immigré dans un
autre pays
et je peux vous dire que je commence en
avoir assez qu'en permanence on essaie
de faire divers sur le dos des immigrés
nous sommes tous en grande partie des
Français de sang-mêlés c'est ce qui fait
la force de notre pays de montrer du
doigt en permanence les immigrés vous
croyez que ça crée quoi dans notre pays
ça crée justement une situation
insupportable ça ne crée pas de cohésion
sociale nous sommes ici des
représentants nationaux notre rôle notre
but c'est de créer de la cohésion c'est
pas de créer de la division entre les
origines de gens de savoir d'où vient un
tel ou un tel c'est pas ça c'est
justement de permettre effectivement une
intégration plus poussée et je dis bien
le mot intégration non pas assimilation
mot que je déteste moi je dis
intégration parce que d'ailleurs vous
pouvez prendre des hommes des Français
ou même vous irez immigré dans un autre
pays vous le souhaiteriez pas être
assimilé vous garderez la fierté d’être
infecté vous êtes très fier votre
identité ça ne vous empêche pas d'avoir
une double culture j'en ai une moi-même
et je peux vous dire qu'elle communique
elle s'entretiennent entre elles et ça
ça permet justement de valoriser des
choses et ça enrichit ça nous enrichit
des emails
en France quand même alors est-ce que
vous il y a deux choses qu'il faut
relativiser je prends l'exemple du Kanak
et surtout souvent pris en exemple par
Hélène d'ailleurs ils prennent souvent
parce que c'est des migrations choisies
effectivement sur la base de diplôme
mais pas exclusivement mais il faut
savoir que là-bas ils accueillent deux
fois plus d'immigrés est-ce que c'est ce
qui est proposé parce que si on regarde
concrètement les problématiques liés
également au taux de natalité autre nous
allons avoir besoin de plus d'immigrés
c'est la réalité c'est la réalité dans
toute l'Europe
à toutes les mesures concernant les
métiers en tension par exemple où on
nous dit j'ai l'impression de la baisse
de la démographie on a besoin de
régulariser les métiers en tout cas
favoriser des personnes qui sont en plus
sur notre sol dans des situations
souvent précaires donc qui ne sont pas
protégés socialement et qui occupent des
emplois quel qu'il soit quel qu'il soit
ils occupent des emplois c'est qu'on a
besoin d'eux mais il faut effectivement
les régulariser je pense que c'est
essentiel parce que ne serait-ce que
pour elle par rapport à notre système
social pour pouvoir les prendre en
charge double chose encore plus
démagogique on parle de l'Ame la
suppression de lime mais on sort d'une
pandémie c'est
une mesure sanitaire
elle peut se diffuser c'est une mesure
sanitaire pour protéger justement les
Français par rapport à des maladies on
ne protégeant pas des gens qui sont sur
notre territoire ça dépend des mesures
ça veut dire je pensais que la pandémie
aurait permis au moins d'avoir une
réflexion là dessus et de comprendre que
justement c'est
Marine Le Pen soit en tête avec des
discours comme cela parce que c'est lié
des réalités
dès la réalité
sur son terrain il y a un moment faut
écouter les Français moi je suis désolé
quand est-ce que le Front National est
au deuxième tour d'élection
présidentielle deux fois après les
gouvernements de gauche une fois après
suivi d'Emmanuel Macron il faut dire la
vérité quand est-ce que le Front
national recule après que les
gouvernements de droite ont eu gouverner
voilà la vérité et pourquoi parce que
nous neions pas les réalités la réalité
et ce qui énerve le français c'est quand
il voit que à l'aide médicale d'État on
vient faire quel que soit qu'ils ne sont
pas des soins d'urgence contrairement à
ce que vous n'avez d'expliquer on n'a
pas de problème sur les soins d'urgence
et sanitaire qui viennent faire des
opérations programmées au titre de l'Ame
ça ça énerve le français qui du coup se
radicalise alors que lui il voit
tranquillement que il paye plus cher sa
santé qu'il a pas accès à un médecin et
il voit que d'autres viennent faire des
soins programmés en France payer par
lui-même allez on passe à un autre sujet
que cette séance de questions au
Gouvernement elle fait la question et
bien de l'ISF climatique en tout cas
l'une des propositions qui a fait Jean
Pisani ferry dans un rapport rendu
public ce lundi Quentin effectivement
c'est un sujet qui a été abordé tout à
l'heure à par la socialiste en gel
previliez mais le point de départ c'est
bien ce rapport remis lundi par
Jean-Pierre un proche d'Emmanuel Macron
il avait même rédigé son programme
économique en 2017 il écrit dans ce
rapport que la décarbonation je cite va
appeler un supplément d'investissement
public et privé de 66 milliards d'euros
par an et dans ce contexte il dit que
les riches doivent aussi participer à
l'effort avec un prélèvement dédié selon
Jean-Pierre et ferry qui pourrait être
assis sur le patrimoine financier
déménage les plus aisés en clair un
impôt en plus pour les plus riches le
ministre de l'économie à très rapidement
fermé la porte à cette idée l'impôt
n'est pas la solution a-t-il dit c'était
hier matin sur RTL mais et bien de son
côté le ministre de la transition
écologique Christophe Béchu a dans un
premier temps en tout cas semblait
ouvert à ce débat sur l'impôt la
taxation des plus riches et légitime
a-t-il dit hier midi changement de ton
lors de cette séance écoutez Christophe
Béchu
la question du financement elle ne peut
pas être tabou mais dans la manière dont
elle est traitée par Monsieur Pisani
Ferri elle évoque plusieurs pistes
d'abord faire en sorte de réorienter les
dépenses nous sommes dans les champions
du monde en termes de prélèvement
obligatoire l'écologie ne doit pas être
le prétexte pour augmenter les impôts il
faut réorienter des dépenses et
réorienter de la fiscalité mais en aucun
cas ne se servir de ce prétexte pour
aller ajouter à une forme d'écologie qui
écartera une partie de nos concitoyens
alors qu'on a besoin de tout le monde
pour réussir compte tenu de l'ampleur du
défi ouais on a vu Christophe Béchu
envoyer des petits tacles comme ça aux
écologistes pendant cette séance on
verra en tout cas quels sont les choix
du gouvernement leur bien de l'annonce
de la planification écologique ce sera
mi-juin Tam
merci beaucoup Quentin Emmanuel Capu
vous êtes plus Christophe Béchu de lundi
ou Christophe Béchu de mercredi un celui
qui se disait ouvert ou celui qui
aujourd'hui d'évidence à fermer la porte
après que Bruno Le Maire a dit c'est pas
possible c'est parce qu'on va faire on
va pas créer de nouvelles impôts pour
les plus aisés je connais assez bien
Christophe depuis assez longtemps pour
savoir qu'il est assez constant dans ses
choix il la redit
qu'il devait pas y avoir de tabou on
était face à des enjeux extrêmement
complexes et inédits et que oh il ne va
y avoir aucun tabou il leur redit tout
de suite
en revanche ce qu'il rajoute aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'elle dit Bruno Le Maire
également ce matin je crois c'est que
la transition écologique doit pas être
un doit pas être un prétexte c'est le
terme qu'il a utilisé je crois tout à
l'heure pour augmenter des impôts sur
une catégorie de personnes en espèces
les personnes qui sont déjà les plus
imposées en réalité
qui existe dans notre pays c'est déjà
des impositions notamment sur les
revenus qui sont progressives et qui
touchent évidemment beaucoup plus les
riches que les pauvres donc il y a
d'autres formes de il faut trouver des
financements il y a d'autres formes de
financement je pense notamment à la
propriété
des choses qui ont été faites notamment
Christelle BECHU avait déposé une
première un projet de loi sur
l'expérimentation du tiers financement
pour la rénovation énergétique des
bâtiments publics qui permet de financer
par des entreprises privées la
rénovation des des bâtiments publics et
les entreprises se rémunèrent sur les
économies d'énergie fournée ça c'est une
une innovation en termes de financement
il y en a plein d'autres et il a dit
aussi il faut réorienter vers la
transition écologique un certain nombre
de sources de financement mais il n'y a
pas besoin à mon sens comme au sens du
ministre de faire de nouvelles impôts
dans un monde globalisé les riches si on
les taxes trop ils partiront et ils
iront ils iront carboné exactement à
l'étranger allez on a parlé une
transition écologique ça a été un des
sujets marquants de cette séance de
questions gouvernement on va tout de
suite rejoindre Alexandre qui se
travaille avec Jacques sternic qui a
tout à l'heure d'ailleurs interpellé le
gouvernement sur cette transition
écologique et notamment sur la question
du frais de ferroviaire effectivement on
parlera dans un instant de la question
du frais de ferroviaire et de
l'opérateur publicité SNCF mais une
réaction Jacques ferrique le ministre
Christophe Béchu dit que l'écologie ne
doit pas être un prétexte pour augmenter
les impôts qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
l'écologie ça doit être une raison
d'agir c'est-à-dire on peut avoir des
débats des discussions on adore les
politiques les polémiques avec des
principes on touchera pas les impôts les
prélèvements obligatoires on sent aussi
un petit peu la volonté d'un
gouvernement de laisser un autre sujet
derrière
ces questions de transition écologique
elles sont sérieuses on le voit sur la
question des transports c'est des
investissements importants le Conseil
d'orientation des infrastructures la
première ministre la validité à choisir
un scénario qui est ambitieux mais qui
est nécessaire
le rapport quizani ferry le travail qui
a été fait sur les trajectoires
climatiques montrent que les politiques
de petits pas minuscule seront
inefficaces seront du gâchis et en plus
seront démoralisantes pour nos
concitoyens nos entreprises notre
économie notre économie qui a besoin
d'être compétitive dans un monde qui est
un monde à venir dans lequel ce qui sera
compétitif ce qui sera efficace c'est ce
qu'on réussit à mettre au point les
technologies les marchés les filières de
la transition écologique on le voit
aujourd'hui sur la question des voitures
électriques on a une petite décennie de
retard sur la Chine notamment et et donc
je prends l'exemple des transports
l'exemple des transports ce qui a permis
à nos voisins je suis d'Alsace en
Allemagne en Suisse dans les pays
nordiques de financer le report moda
l'important qui fait que pour eux
l'objectif de 30% de par modèle des
marchandises sur les trains est un
objectif atteignable dans les 10 ans
parce qu'ils ont su faire payer la route
ils ont su appliquer un principe pollue
qui est un principe qui a pas qui est
pas ruineux pour les chargeurs qui par
ruineux pour les transporteurs qui
permet simplement de mettre de la
rigueur de de pousser à de
l'organisation la massification des
transports et qui donne les moyens aux
frais de ferroviaire d'avoir son
efficacité justement vous avez interrogé
le gouvernement sur cette question du
frais de ferroviaire puisque
l'entreprise publique en charge de ce
secteur Fred SNCF étant danger la
Commission européenne menace de lui
mettre une amende pour aide illégale
d'État pourrait disparaître cette
entreprise il y a quand même 4800
salariés et le ministre des Transports
Clement Beaune lui est en train de
négocier un accord pour sauver cette
entreprise Fret SNCF la restructurer
peut-être diminuer un petit peu sa
capacité en presser en préservant je
cite 90% des effectifs est-ce que cet
accord qui est en train de négocier
Clément Boon il vous satisfait il est
plus en train de négocier vu que
l'accord qu'il a qu'il a convenu avec la
commission il est là cet accord c'est
une sorte de capit situation dès le
départ dès le départ
cette affaire date de janvier la France
avait un mois pour présenter ses
arguments si je me trompe c'est à peu
près ça le l'ordre de grandeur il y a un
contentieux un anneau qui concerne
l'Allemagne
la procédure engagée c'est pour des
années
c'est pas comme ça en une décision
annoncé hier qui décide que Fred SNCF
n'existe plus en tant que tel frais SNCF
on aurait pu le droit d'employer ce
terme commercial c'est ça sera deux
entités deux entités en abandonnant à la
concurrence tout ce qui est très complet
c'est la disparition de 500 postes
d'emploi existant aujourd'hui sur fret à
SNCF c'est l'interdiction de fêter SNCF
de concourir à des appels d'offres pour
des années des années sur les trains
complets donc c'est quand même un
démantèlement important au moment où on
a besoin d'un fret ferroviaire public
qui soit en excellente état de marche
pour que le rebond ferroyeur on
réussisse on sent que nous n'êtes pas du
tout satisfait par cet accord
de quoi négocier merci beaucoup Jacques
ferrique d'être venu à mon micro merci
merci beaucoup
[Musique]
dans son rapport mais c'est ce qui fait
le plus parler c'est le fait d'imposer
les plus riches pour financer la
transition écologique c'est une bonne
chose là je entre elles oui c'est une
bonne chose et nous ça fait un moment
qu'on le réclame ça fait plus de 4 ans
qu'on réclame justement à la mise en
place d'un ISF climatique pour une
raison très simple quand vous regardez
même les phénomènes de réchauffement
climatique ceux qui sont le plus touché
c'est pas les plus riches eux peuvent
s'en protéger quelque part avec leurs
moyens financiers sont justement aussi
bien les pays les plus pauvres les
personnes qui sont les plus pauvres mais
même au sein des pays ça sera des
personnes les plus démunies donc la
transition pour les plus pauvres donc la
transition écologique doit
automatiquement inclure une politique de
justice sociale et d'égalité sociale
pour une raison très simple c'est qu'en
plus de ça les plus riches sont aussi
les personnes qui polluent le plus c'est
ça la forte injustice qui est également
pollueur qui la personne qui pollue le
plus doit contribuer le plus à la
transition écologique c'est un principe
aussi simple par contre par rapport à ce
qui vient d'être dit c'est vrai qu'il y
a un taux de fiscalité importante en
France on peut même dire 50% en moyenne
mais le gros problème et qui enragent
les Français c'est plus vous montez dans
l'échelle pas plus vous payez d'impôts
c'est faux c'est l'inverse moi vous
payez d'impôts on passe à 25% et même je
vous donne une étude de monsieur zuckman
qui est un chercheur français qui est
aux États-Unis qui a montré que les très
riches c'était 2%.
distributif aujourd'hui
la classe moyenne en peine 50% vous
trouvez ça juste c'est profondément
injuste alors que c'est eux qui polluent
le plus donc il faut que les riches
payent leur part et là on parle d'un
besoin de 25 milliards mais café
Emmanuel Macron depuis 2017 il n'a fait
que diminuer les impôts du plus riches
on a parlé de l'ISF 3 milliards à peu
près par an depuis qu'il est élu faites
le compte vous allez voir vous arrivez
au besoin qu'on a la tvae 8 milliards et
c'est ça flat tax encore des milliards
en fait revenus du capital il a baissé
encore des milliards donc en fait le
bilan c'est que depuis quelque part
Pisani ferry ce qui fait c'est vraiment
une condamnation en règle du bilan des
manuel Macron en la matière puisque
les impôts sur le patrimoine et le
revenu financier des plus riches alors
qu'il faut justement à juste titre comme
le distributeur faire l'inverse et c'est
ce que nous proposons il faut faire
l'inverse Jérôme bachaire qu'est-ce que
vous
j'imagine que la droite n'est pas
favorable au rétablissement de l'ISF
mais comment on fait à ce moment-là je
connais jean-physat di ferry depuis
presque un quart de siècle et c'est
toujours un économiste de gauche
d'un excellent économiste vraiment
vraiment très bon mais vraiment de
gauche donc il a proposé quoi de taxer
les 10% qui gagnait le plus c'est eux
qui concentre 75 % de l'impôt sur le
revenu tout simplement 75% de la poche
sur le revenu et de faire de la dette
moi j'avais pas compris qu'on était en
manque de dette en France alors ce qui
est certain c'est qui
c'est pas la même chose que les autres
que d'autres dates utiles quand le pays
est ruiné vous faites rien du tout pour
le climat ça je peux vous assurer que là
c'est terminé donc là on a sur un vrai
sujet on a su être transformation qui
est un sujet de transformation en France
et je crois qu'il a commencé bien
commencé et que les financements
d'ailleurs sont là pour le faire il y a
pas de de vrai sujet de ce point de vue
là il y a pas de sujet de problèmes de
finances
on peut faire quoi décarboner les
industries par des incitations qu'est-ce
qui est déjà il y a tout ça dans le plan
de relance qui va nous coûter juste de
la dette et qui va rien relancer du tout
donc le sujet c'est que les entreprises
sont en train de s'en charger très
normalement tranquillement parce que
sinon ils ne pourront plus avoir accès à
des développements mais le sujet n'est
pas que franco-français c'est bien ça le
problème une fois encore on essaye de
traiter le problème climatique de par le
monde uniquement avec notre nombril
français et bien ça me semble pas tout à
fait la bonne mesure il faudrait un vrai
plan de verdissement européen déjà je
suis pas sûr que les Allemands soient
totalement d'accord là-dessus vous voyez
sur l'industrie automobile allemande
avec les accords avec les Chinois qui
sont très en avance vous avez monsieur
d'avance les Chinois il faut voir
comment et à quel prix donc si c'est ça
son modèle je le comprends ce n'est pas
tout à fait mon modèle de pollution la
Chine si les voitures c'est ce qu'il y a
de mieux en Chine je crois qu'il n'a pas
bien regardé comment on produisait
l'électricité des voitures électriques
quand il me semble que c'est au charbon
donc c'est fermé il vient de nous dire
sur notre planète sur votre plateau que
avec la Chine et bien le modèle
électrique chinois était le bon il faut
faire du charbon je ne crois pas allez
dernière thématique de ce débrief des
questions au gouvernement et bien on
revient sur Vertbaudet alors qu'une
grève des salariés dure déjà depuis deux
mois deux mois de mobilisation pour
réclamer des augmentations de salaire de
questions tout à l'heure à Manon de la
gauche lors de cette séance de questions
au Gouvernement écouter ce qui se disait
tout à l'heure dans l'hémistice la mare
jeunette est passée de - 0,7% à plus de
3 ,1 la valeur ajoutée de 49
,7 millions à 56,6 millions d'euros et
sur la même période la part des salaires
par rapport au chiffre d'affaires et
passer de 15,6% à
12,1%. l'unique revendication de ces
salariés est une augmentation de salaire
de 150 euros la solidarité le soutien de
tout le monde du travail s'exprime y
compris financièrement et quelques par
cette lutte est devenue celle de tous
les salariés du pays par procuration ce
conflit social est bien connu des
services de mon ministère et de mon
cabinet il a été ouvert autour du 20
mars et un accord a été signé d'accord
majoritaire sur lequel vous pouvez avoir
une appréciation signé par deux
organisations syndicales Force ouvrière
et la CFE-CGC en soulignant que ces deux
organisations représentent lors des
dernières consultations 63% des
suffrages exprimés dans l'entreprise il
y a une centrale est-ce que vous
soutenez ce mouvement des grévistes de
Vertbaudet alors que on l'a entendu le
ministre vient de le dire la CGT reste
minoritaire et il un accord qui a été
validé notamment par FO et la CFTC il y
a 70 grevistes aujourd'hui sur 327
salariés oui on les soutient en plus
comme je vous dis on vient de sortir
d'un débat sur la réforme des retraites
où on a parlé de la nécessité de
revaloriser le travail revaloriser le
travail c'est pas à travers des primes
c'est à travers le salaire là ce qui est
proposé c'est pas une revalorisation
salariale c'est 0% d'augmentation de
salaire donc ce qu'elle réclame à juste
titre c'est d'avoir des revenus décents
pour pouvoir travailler et je pense que
ça c'est d'accord c'est ce que vous dit
aussi le ministre c'est ce que dit aussi
la direction qu'est-ce que vous
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à ça ça
c'est des éléments de langage est-ce
qu'ils défense les salariés de notre
pays et un travail
rémunérateurs
la question elle est plutôt là et la
beauté un peu en touche en disant ça
c'est parce qu'on est notre groupe a
également posé une question sur le sujet
est-ce que il est favorable à des
augmentations des augmentations de
salaire pour les travailleurs ou non
c'est pas de reporter de battre en
touche sur les syndicats quand ça les
arrange alors qu'ils les ont pas
consultés pendant la réforme des
retraites donc ça c'est un peu facile je
pense que les syndicats eux-mêmes n'ont
pas dû être très satisfait de cette
réponse donc ce qu'il faut c'est surtout
qu'on parle de transition écologique on
parle aussi de pouvoir avoir une frappe
fabrication française c'est pouvoir de
monter en gamme donc monter en gamme
c'est aussi monter en gamme pour les
rémunérations des personnes qui
effectuent ces travaux c'est ça qui
c'est ça qui est essentiel il faut
rémunérer beaucoup plus les gens qui
travaillent vous pouvez pas rester au
SMIC aux revenus minimum tout votre vie
et oui c'est entre 1300 et 1500 euros
les salaires dans cette entreprise après
plus de 20 ans d'ancienneté pour
certaines de ces ouvrières on peut
comprendre notamment qu'avec la
situation actuelle l'inflation qui court
c'est compréhensible de demander plus
que des primes aujourd'hui non mais il
faut pas tout confondre il y a un
conflit social interne à une entreprise
privée avec et ça c'est pas des éléments
de langage un accord de véritable dans
une entreprise privée il y a le dialogue
social les partenaires sociaux discutent
les syndicats majoritaires discutent il
y a un accord majorité avec tes
syndicats majoritaires CFTC faux qui a
été trouvé sur des primes et sur donc
des augmentations ponctuelles et il y a
une tentative on a vu avoir on voit bien
et une tentative de récupération ce
conflit social interne c'est pas l'état
de régler ce conflit social interne il
peut soit il l'administrer très bien dit
peut faire de la médiation il peut aider
des gens enfin c'est pas à l'état
d'aller dans les entreprises dire
combien les entreprises privées alors il
y a une je pense qu'il y a une tentative
de récupération d'un syndicat
minoritaire au sein de l'entreprise ce
qu'on voit madame Binet qui débarque
pour essayer de transformer ce conflit
interne en revendication nationale sur
les salaires et là effectivement on sait
tous que il y a l'inflation il y a des
difficultés évidemment des Français à
avec les fins de mois et là je pense que
c'est autre chose et on aura des
occasions pour discuter un débat sur la
loi travail sur le sur le partage de la
valeur mais ça c'est autre chose et je
pense pas qu'il faille récupérer des
situations particulières pour en faire
des étend rap rapidement il y a une
volonté de nationaliser le conflit mais
est-ce que c'est pas légitime dans le
contexte actuel
c'était très bien dit préparer un
collègue communiste ça permet de
l'argent
ça perdait de l'argent il sait à deux
doigts de la marginette était négatif ça
s'appelle perdre de l'argent et donc là
il se sentent pas forcément je ne rentre
pas dans le dans le conflit lui-même
chacun est légitime la CGT et légitime
dire je ne suis pas d'accord il y a il y
a un accord signé il est légitime très
bien l'entreprise à la banquier de
déposer le bilan
vraiment pas bien mais certains en
revanche que le sujet des salaires
aujourd'hui se pose en 2023 car en 2022
grosso modo au niveau national les
salaires ont augmenté dans le privé et
pas dans le public et on a un phénomène
dans le public d'ailleurs je crois que
il y a des éducation qui vont s'ouvrir
mais il y a un énorme sujet vous savez
que depuis 2010 les fonctionnaires ont
perdu 18% de pouvoir d'achat 18% ces
deux mois de salaire c'est deux mois
de salaire écoutez voilà au moins un
sujet sur lequel on voit la gauche
accessé
et les RPS sont d'accord là dessus voici
pour une sur la paupérisation des
fonctionnaires évidemment
participé à ce débrief des questions
gouvernement on se retrouve tout de
suite dans avoir 20 ans un numéro une
émission consacrée à la santé sexuelle
l'éducation sexuelle des jeunes alors
que les infections sexuellement
transmissibles sont en hausse depuis 20
ans très bonne suite des programmes sur
public c'est là
[Musique]
ou au revoir votre programme
sur publicena.fr
depuis le début du conflit en Ukraine la
guerre froide n'a jamais été autant
d'actualité
pour les Chinois la guerre froide avec
les États-Unis a commencé à la fin de la
dernière guerre froide en 1987
donc il y a vraiment un risque important
de déflagration tout ou tard il faut le
comprendre la Chine dépassera les
États-Unis
aujourd'hui c'est une vraie menace et le
département américain de la Défense on
est conscient il passe à Taïwan c'est
presque plus important que ce qui se
passe en Ukraine alors ta gueule je ne
crois pas que cela ressemblera à
l'ancienne guerre froide car c'est
impossible pour les États-Unis de
contenir la Chine c'est
Chine États-Unis la nouvelle guerre
froide samedi à 22h30 sur Public Sénat
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour à tous et ravi de vous
retrouver dans ce nouveau numéro d'avoir
20 ans un numéro qui se penche
aujourd'hui sur la santé sexuelle des
jeunes l'occasion de parler d'éducation
sexuelle c'est court que malheureusement
trop peu de jeunes suivent aujourd'hui
en France mais aussi de s'interroger sur
la recrudescence des infections
sexuellement transmissibles les IST sont
en hausse depuis 20 ans et oui il est
loin le temps ou le message sortait
couvert était sur toutes les ondes et
pour parler de tous ces sujets j'ai le
plaisir d'accueillir Morgan Le Bastard
bonjour vous avez 25 ans vous êtes
animatrice d'éducation à la sexualité
dans un centre de santé sexuelle à
Aubervilliers c'est en Seine-Saint-Denis
vous êtes aussi actuellement étudiante à
l'université Paris Cité vous préparez un
du un diplôme universitaire de santé
sexuelle et droits humains merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous à côté de vous
Manon bonjour bonjour vous avez 28 ans
vous venez de Paris vous êtes créatrice
du compte Instagram le cunu et vous êtes
la matrice du livre le cul mise à nu le
livre qui déculotte nos idées reçues
tout un programme c'est paru chez
Hachette en 2021 je crois même que vous
allez sortir récemment même un jeu un
jeu de société qui s'appelle le quiz
absolument voilà avec encore un jeu de
mots vous êtes également chroniqueuse
dans le podcast hotline sur Spotify
face à vous Sarah du rocher bonjour vous
êtes présidente nationale du planning
familial et enfin j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir sur ce plateau Jean-Luc
Romero Michel bonjour vous êtes adjoint
à la mer de Paris chargée des droits
humains de l'intégration de la lutte
contre les discriminations et vous êtes
également président des liloko contre le
sida et pour commencer je vous propose à
tous de partir à Marseille cette ville
qui a reçu par votre association
Jean-Luc Romero le label de ville engagé
contre le sida alors qu'elles ont été
les projets les infrastructures mises en
place pour lutter contre le VIH
reportage de Mathias Arès et Emma garbou
Lorenzon I
à Marseille le spot Longchamp est un
lieu à part
elle va voir directement où il va avoir
directement que la personne est basculée
dans sa salle d'attente donc on va la
vertu qu'il y a quelqu'un qui l'a voilà
il y a une personne à la salle d'attente
ici on accueille entre autres des
personnes infectées par différentes
maladies sexuellement transmissibles ou
qui craignent pour leur santé après une
exposition à un risque
ici au sport l'ensemble surtout c'est
l'écoute d'abord de les écouter sans le
juger donc du coup quel qu'en soit leur
orientation sexuelle quelle qu'en soit
leur pratique sexuelle quelle que soit
l'air consommation de produits parce que
la plupart des contaminations c'est des
jeunes aussi donc du coup c'est un
problème qu'on en a pas comme si le sida
n'existe pas alors qu'il y a toujours
des contamination il y a toujours des
découvertes de contamination bien
couvert depuis 2016 le spot Longchamp
s'inscrit depuis l'an dernier dans un
plan à plus grande échelle voulu sur la
commune des Bouches-du-Rhône vers
Marseille sans sida sans hépatite une
association qui fédère tous les acteurs
de la lutte contre le VIH objectif
mutualiser certains moyens pour pousser
dans la même direction des actions pour
le problème des sommes on a fait la
première campagne
d'information à Marseille sur tous les
outils disponibles pour lutter contre le
VIH et les hépatives mais surtout les
VIH c'était le 1er décembre donc une
campagne d'affichage dans le métro sur
les bus sur les quais de métro et en
même temps on a mis en place
un guide de prescription d'aide à la
prescription pour les médecins de ville
pour la prep donc la prophylaxie de
pré-exposition qui est un outil
supplémentaire pour se prémunir contre
contre